just press that one
today
good morning everyone uh everybody
um welcome to this full council meeting
I've the protocol to read out in a
second I just uh firstly like pay
comment to the late uh Chris Chris
brimblecomb who passed away
uh Cliff brimblekin who passed away
uh his widow uh went before him so my
condolence to his families
uh to his family he was chairman of this
Authority and a councilor of many years
standing so you're sad to note his
passing so thank you
uh I'd like to welcome Charles who's
been
I'm Who I'm standing in for uh he's
getting better as you see him in the
front he's looking much better after a
short spell of illness but he's getting
back to full health and I'm he's already
told me intense to chair the next
council meeting in a fortnight so we've
well done for getting better
and nice to see you here and yeah move
on right
uh so there's no fire alarm test is
planned and should the fire alarm sound
please leave the room and stand by the
far end of the car park
um please raise your hand if you wish to
speak and a boom microphone will be
brought over to you if you don't speak
into the microphone you'll not be heard
on the live stream otherwise please
remain seated
please keep points short and ask members
not to repeat points that they've
already been raised and voting will be
by a show of hands and should the
meeting be a drone adjourned any filming
must cease unless the by the express
permission from those being filmed has
been obtained during any adjournment I
would ask that members of public and
officers please leave the room until the
meeting reconvenes
uh thank you very much indeed so we
moved to item one which is apologies for
absence Sarah have counselors foden
Gribble Haynes Hayes Jenks pet cook
Evans Swain Nutley and Eden
Parker Khan
Aleister
yeah just to say counselor cookies in
Tollway Hospital
oh I'm sorry to hear that our best
wishes to her obviously go from all the
members I'm sure
right and we moved to item two uh
Declarations of interest if any
members any Declarations of Interest
counselors Richard
hi there I've got a declaration of
interest that I'm uh uh director of the
not-for-profit uh Community benefits
Society the Alexandra theater Newton
abbots I asked for dispensation to uh
partake in the debate and uh and vote on
this matter uh because uh my
understanding of LGA rules is that uh
not-for-profit directorships are not
pecuniary interests I've been given
dispensation to uh to speak to the
motion but not to partake in the debate
and vote uh I therefore ask if other
councilors with similar interests in
not-for-profits operating in a new
number have been offered the same
dispensation thank you
thank you Richard for that uh councilor
Phil bullovan
can I move that the council will be
allowed to take part and vote in this
meeting please
right there's a show of hands for that
uh you want to speak can I can I confirm
it's not for the council determinants
for the monitoring officer to determine
whether there is an interest in that
we've had a view that there isn't a um
or the interest is there monitoring
officer is given a view which is the
ability for the councilor to speak prior
to the debate but not take part in the
debate and vote
what you want to chat
carry on
thank you chair
um actually first I should congratulate
you on um having um looked at your
conscience and left the condemn Alliance
and um become an independent member
um but the point I wanted to make
um is that um surely officers
um advise accounts or the council is The
Sovereign body here we make decisions
um and this is this is not a point of
law something that we cannot do as
councilor laws has pointed out he would
be acting in the court with local
government
sort of guidance on this so I I suggest
that we do um take the vote as put
forward as we're entitled to
the Constitution is a document that sets
out that there is an interest here
um uh and the Constitution if if you
want to go against the Constitution
um I think you know if you really say
that you don't want to follow our
constitution then that's a matter for
members
um I would suggest that that is an
inappropriate thing to be doing given
um the interests that members have uh in
terms of the second question asked by
Council of doors we only advise members
who have given their expression of
interest and told us what that is and
then asked for a dispensation it's for
members to decide
uh ciao I'd like to suggest that the
argument that it would be against the
Constitution is a little Rich
um when this this um this Council has
over the last sort of three and a half
years many times gone against the
Constitution indeed the current
monitoring officer has acted against the
Constitution
um I I think it is within the
Constitution that that our council is
Sovereign and we can decide to vote on
this
thank you chair
um I think um the big problem we've got
here is that we're suggesting that this
is a constitutional matter it's actually
a matter of law
the government have laid out in the
localism ACT 2011 the grounds for
pecuniary interests and provided a very
detailed description and definition of
what is and what is not a pecuniary
interest within the terms of the
localism ACT
the current Council model goes beyond
the legal minimum requirement and that
is a bit of a worry if the government is
setting out what the actual terms of
pecuniary interests are and we are going
beyond that to restrict debate and
potentially
leave members of the community outside
the debate that's a worry thank you
sorry can I just clarify that the the
counselor is correct in terms of the
localism act in terms of what was there
it's pecuniary interest
the council as part of the LGA the LGA
did go beyond the act and thought it was
appropriate for directors of
not-for-profit companies who have
registerable interests in that sense not
to be party and the model code adopted
by the council in principle and the
lga's advice was that directors who have
a directorship even though it's not for
profit but those companies shouldn't
take part in the debate so they have
ability to talk to give a view prior to
the debate but not to debate and not to
vote where they have a direct interest
in the outcome of that decision so
clearly if you you know if this was a
decision that we were making that has a
direct impact on the directorship of a
organization or a body or the benefit of
that that's where the OJ was giving
advice so it's giving advice on the
basis that counselors weren't actually
acting in the interests of their
directorship which is their primary
responsibility so as a director you have
your responsibility first to the company
secondly to the council into taxpayers
right councilor condom
um thank you chairman I I suppose apart
from cancer Jules no member will be
familiar with the conversations that
councilor doors will have had with the
monitoring officer all of the details
and all the implications what I've heard
the managing director describe is the
considerations in the code of conduct
that it's wider than simply a financial
interest which is councilor doors
rightly says is non-pecuniary in that
sense but is an interest in terms of a
council asset for example
um
I don't think that it should be put to a
vote but if it is going to be put
together I will vote against simply
because uh I can't be familiar with the
all of the details that Council doors
will have had in conversation with the
bondage officer I'm not in a position
about a judge on that I have heard the
managing director give advice and I will
accept that advice in the absence of
anything else chairman and I think then
you know the vote either needs to be put
or cancelable of them you know withdraws
it whichever it is I don't mind but I've
ever against German
cancer Liam Miller
the leaders has pointed out that he
agrees it's not a pecuniary interest but
but by the terms of which he has said
councilor Dawes does have an interest
apply entirely to councilors Wrigley and
hook being members of the Newton Abbott
cic so if you are going to misread your
own constitution in order to disinclude
councilor doors can we please at least
not be Hypocrites and also disinclude
these two councilors at least play by a
straight bat here please
there was another counselor here
councilor Mike Hocking
yeah thank you chair um just a bit of
clarity really I thought this um this
meeting today was going to be debating
the the possibility of us borrowing 600
000 extra for the cinema that's nothing
to do with Alexander theater and I
cannot see how cancer doors
um being being part of the Alexander
theater oh
um whatever it is he's belongs to that I
cannot see how that interferes or even
comes in question of the cinema so I
don't really know what we're debating
and what we're arguing about as far as I
can see the cinemas has completely
separate issue to the Alexandra theater
thank you uh very much councilor Mike
Hawking well
sorry I was about to speak but councilor
Martin Wrigley
after me well all I was going to say was
in view of the debate that we've had so
far how does councilor Richard Dawes
feel about this I mean I don't think
he's being over disadvantaged here with
the fact that he's going to speak on it
he's not being asked to leave the room
at the end of the day he's going to sit
there and listen to the debate so how do
you feel Richard do you feel you're
being disadvantaged and would you like
to vote or where are we
yeah thanks very much for the uh for the
question chair so I feel uh I I'd agree
with councilor Hocking uh it pertains to
the cinema funding uh the reason I
declared an interest is as the the
cinema uh has uh a an impact on a
potential uh not-for-profit organization
that I may be involved in in the future
should it get off the ground
um what I would uh be very aggrieved is
if other counselors with similar
interests in already operating
not-for-profits the new knob at cic
already operates facilities within the
town already operates rents rooms out it
would be in direct competition in being
a facility within the within the town uh
with the business that is about to be uh
debated to be funded uh so I I I would
uh halt back to Kansas the Malone's idea
of play it with a straight bar either I
am allowed to vote or counselors uh
Wrigley and and hook who are directors
of the new number cic step back and
don't vote as well thank you
so what you're saying is you'd very much
like to take part in the debate uh
rather than just speaking and vote at
the same time
so can I just confer with the managing
director for a second to see
what he makes of that
future
four counselors you don't make me a
decision
well I'm told it's for councilors who
can Wrigley to decide whether they've
got an interest to declare
well we're gonna uh um are you
withdrawing your your
counselor Wrigley uh thank you chair
um yes I am a director of the Newton
Abbott cic yes the Newton Abbott cic
operates the Buckland Center and the
Courtney Center within the town
I don't believe those are impacted in
any way whatsoever with any of the
business uh under discussion today I
don't see there being any connection
whatsoever with it I would happily take
advice from the monitoring officer I
have written to the monitoring officer
about this I've yet to receive a reply
um but I don't believe there is any uh
interest to declare in the business
today that pertains to the Newton Abbot
CRC I don't think it has anything to do
with today's business
okay so that's cleared that up from
those counselor
thank you chair
um yeah similarly I did look at this um
I I would never want to be in a
situation where I hadn't declared an
interest
um so um I have declared my interest as
a director of Newton Abbott cic on the
web for all to see uh beyond that it
says um from what I've read where a
matter arises a meeting which directly
relates to one of your disclosable
pecuniary interest
um then then I obviously need to declare
it and take the action required
um I do not feel as councilor Wrigley
has said that this matter directly
relates to this um interest as a
director it has no the Newton Abbott cic
has no
um it has General objectives within the
town of Newton Abbot
um and nothing that is directly related
to the decision that we're about to make
today okay thank you
well I'd like to come back to councilor
full Philippines
proposal it still stands the oh sorry
bigger pun councilman Linda pedry
thank you chair
um
I the monitoring offer has spoken to me
about
um counselor hook and councilor Wrigley
and I think if he was here he would
probably say that the same applies to
councilor hook and councilor Wrigley as
it just counts the door and doors and I
think In fairness it probably
would be fair that they they all were
allowed to speak but not vote
maybe have your proposition again uh
Council but
I'm I'm unaware of that conversation
Council Patrick
um you know I'm I'm
the the the interest we have isn't it
which we're talking about is is
um Council of doors expressed an
interest and asked to review on it
um it's for members to determine whether
they feel they need to come forward and
whether they have a a clear conscience
in the sense of their role pecuniary
interests are interesting because
peculiar interests are there and if you
take part in a debate that then has a
positive impact on that business or that
operation uh it's then a criminal
offense slightly different from
registerable interests this is a
registered interest
um
my my view and my conversations with the
monitoring officer was that uh that you
know I haven't discussed at length to be
perfectly Frank anything to do with
counselor hook or councilor Wrigley in
terms of Council of doors Council of
doors is uh the director of the
community benefits society which has put
a planning application into the council
and it has applied for funding to set up
a building so as to set up an
organization that will provide cultural
activities within the data center
uh I I'm I'm afraid I disagree with
councilor Hocking because obviously
whether the cinema goes ahead or doesn't
go ahead has a significant impact on the
future of culture which cultural
activities in the Alexandra that was the
sense of where we are
I I would give my own personal view
which is I'm you know we're not talking
about direct impacts upon the community
interest company in terms of the
Courtney Center or that this is a far
far greater impact in terms of how the
future of the Alexandra operates
compared to what might happen to the
Courtney Center or the Mary Rose Center
thank you councilor patch
thank you chair we've heard from a
member of this Council that the
monitoring officer has the view that all
three members ought to be treated the
same is it's a great shame that the
monitoring officer isn't here to sort of
shed further light on this I wonder if
you or anyone else is able to confirm is
this non-attendance at all related to
the thorny issues thrown up by these
three councilors
um participation chairman chairman this
is distasteful Mr Woodhead has actually
had to have an operation last week he's
unable to attend to suggest that it's
because he's afraid to duck a question I
think is inappropriate and really quite
rude
um yeah thank you Mr you're attempting
to smear me in some way there I
deliberately phrased I deliberately
phrased my question
um in a way that avoided any possibility
that there might be personal reasons for
attending this
um as as to whether it might be related
to this issue you have introduced the
personal situation of an employee into
public debate here I did not you did do
not attempt to smear me for your
disgusting behavior in this matter
councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um I I think the um there is actually
um a slight crossover here and I think
from the point of view of the um
managing director's comments regarding
the cultural aspect of of what's
happening in the creation of a cultural
quarter I attended recently a liberal
Democrat meeting at the Courtney Center
and on the ground level of that building
was a cultural event it was a piano
recycle
so if there's going to be a a cultural
quarter or a cultural effort made with
the Alexandra theater in future that has
a direct impact potentially on the
Courtney Center
so if there is going to be there a a a
conflict of interest it's very clear
that any creation of a new venue for
that kind of event is going to impact on
other locations within the town and
therefore anybody who's a member of the
cic is potentially arguing or debating
from a position where they're going to
know what's going on and the other
element that is looking to create is not
going to so I think we should really
just go for a level of consistency
that's all we're asking for here a level
of consistency that says where there is
an interest
whether it's pecuniary or otherwise we
take a consistent approach people can
debate it but I think they don't vote on
it thank you
councilor Liam Malone
at every meeting I've been at to discuss
the new plans for the Alexandra and to
meet with all the people that you know
usually at the Courtney Center
either counselor hook or Wrigley or both
of them have been there swaying the
argument trying to move things in their
Direction putting their point across as
directors of the cic it's pretty rich
for them to come along now and try and
put a a paper wall in between this and
and what they represent and saying we're
not an interested party
as Council Connor would like a word
chairman if I'm able to I'd like to
chairman if I'm able to I'd like to
propose that the question is put
well
before I've got something to say if I
may before that I'd like to try and take
the heat of this is out it's surely it's
up to the member to decide and that's
councilor Richard Dawes If he wants to
vote and speak on it it's up to him
whether he wants to do so or not and he
he as I say in my years of experience of
being a counselor he runs the gauntlet
if he's if he's held in order to be
brought before the powers that be
because he's out of order
so we've heard from him we know what
interests he's got and everything so you
know I I would like just to to let the
meeting carry on if he wants to he's
going to stay anyway and he's going to
be here anyway if he wants to put up his
hand and speak and speak and what have
you if he does anything out of order it
it's up it's up for the monitoring
people to do
just out the so-called punishments the
before people when they step out of
order so you know that's as I said now
you you want to go to the vote on this
um councilor Phil bullerman would you
like to repeat what your your emotion
was
I believe it's important that we've got
47 counselors here sorry it's important
to remember we've got 47 councils who
respect who have a will have a view on
this
the facility in Newton Abbot there are
approximately 16 councilors who
potentially are users of this facility
anyway
so the difficulty is how do you define I
will go to that Cinema I've gone to the
previous Cinema am I therefore guilty of
passing a vote because I've got an
interest in that Cinema
I just think for
democracy one voting 47
with a voice that has got qualifications
to be heard
should be allowed to take part in the
discussion and debate and vote
that is democracy I do appreciate the
limitations and I do agree that the
responsibility rests with the individual
for that reason I my motion was used to
allow Council doors to speak and vote
remains thank you and you had you
seconded that did you not counselor
McGregor Council I I want to go to the
vote on this uh councilor patch could
you persistent that we've heard a lot
from you let's have finally from you
very briefly please
I do appreciate that chair and I'm
attempting to find a solution here which
might be acceptable to a to a broad
number of members and that is I would
like to propose an amendment that all
three members at with the primer facing
facts before us be treated in the same
way in this in this meeting
would anybody second that
uh right counseling below secondly we've
got to take the amendment first uh and
yes
it's not a matter for the council I
think actually you summarized it
councilor Dawes has taken advice on the
monitoring officer is advice councilor
doors can choose to follow it or not if
he doesn't you've set out the Peril that
any councilor anywhere might face the
risk off
um
now you're saying it's not massively
cancer and without interruption chairman
the amendment the amendment speaks to
other people it's not for the council
decide who does or doesn't have an
interest councilor hook and councilor
Wrigley have expressed their
understanding councilor Wrigley says
he's written to the monitoring officer
and awaits a reply and you rightly
pointed out just to recap that it's a
matter of the council adores whether he
takes the advice and that there may be
apparel if he chooses not to these
matters are not for the council to vote
on and I was asking for the vote to be
put because we might be into four
o'clock discussing the Constitution
foreign
I can confirm that Jim and it is not for
the council to decide who and hasn't got
interest in terms of having a vote to
decide whether they feel that cancer
Wrigley or hook have got an interest
it's for councilor hook and Wrigley to
determine whether they come forward with
that
um they've they've made a decision you
shouldn't be bringing that into this
conversation because it is relevant for
it
and this long protracted Road of having
amendments and so and so we're going to
be here in an awful amount of time we've
we've we've heard that now that
councilor Richard Dawes as far as I can
see it would like to take part in the uh
debate as well and vote on it haven't we
so he runs the Roth the same as any
other counselor on that I don't think
there's any necessary to have any votes
whatsoever on anything I have to say it
it's fairly clear and and whether we're
going to be here for a long period of
time and that is my solution I I think
you'll find he's going to speak are you
gonna stay uh you you've made it
perfectly clear councilor Richard Dawson
I finally hear from you you're going to
State you're going to be a part of the
meeting and debate it and vote on it is
that correct yeah yes that that's
correct the reason I didn't partake in
the previous debate is that I was told
by the monitoring officer that I'd be uh
undertaking a criminal offense by doing
so I think the managing director has
just said it's different today so I'm
slightly confused by the advice that
I've been given but I I don't believe
that I am uh I have a an interest that
is that constitutes a criminal offense
members can I have a straw poll put your
hands up please if you're happy that for
the meeting to move on
the basis of the Assurance I withdraw
the question thank you that has helped
me out a lot and you've withdrawn as
well and so I think we can we know
what's going to happen maybe may I move
on please members yes thank you very
much for the compromise and the way
you've handled it as you know I like to
try and give everybody their say but uh
we're not going to be here too much
longer because we got that out very
contentious thing if you like out the
way so thank you very much we've got an
amicable solution here so let's move on
to uh item four which is uh item three
what
there's no more Declarations of Interest
so we're moving to three we're moving to
three all right yeah I I said four I
meant three right so it's um the
chairman of the audit scrutiny committee
Sally Morgan to introduce this item
pictures Pages 23 to 20. two on your
agenda thank you Sally thank you I'll be
very quick because we discussed this on
3rd of November and we propose that we
accept the resolution of the demon audit
partnership with one uh change to their
recommendation and that was to uh
increase the priority of uh the creation
of a stakeholder management plan and
that was it and we I propose that we
just note this report thank you
thank you very much Alan
that report uh if you like came before
I'll just remind members that at that
moment Sally chaired the meeting
councilor Mary Cole Clough was there
councilor Hugh Cox was there and
councilor Linda Goodman Bradbury was
there
this report was unanimous I did abstain
because I could see myself being in the
chair and I didn't want to be accused of
having any bias and that so it was
unanimous apart from my extension that
we thought that we went that way from
that meeting because this came before
the audit committee now are you happy
for me to uh you'll have to excuse me I
forgot to mute my phone
yeah no it wasn't a budget it was
awfully sorry about that
um
so members uh are you happy to note this
report and we move on please can I have
a just a show of hands as it's only a
noting of a report
is anybody against not noting the report
right thank you very much thank you
Sally my apologies about the phone going
off
right we move now to item four which is
the future High Street fund uh project
and we've got the uh entertainment
services solution Limited in attendance
with Rob Arthur and he's going to
address the the members on on this item
which is the future High Street fund
um
Cinema report so where's Rob at the back
right with the microphone to you sir and
Carol carry on
good morning can you hear me okay
yes great I I thought it'd be useful to
split down the uh report and I I didn't
want to do a formal presentation the
documentation there's a lot of
documentation around this it's all
available for the members and counselors
but I thought you were supposed to talk
about the market overview Newton Abbott
in particular uh the viability and I
have some question and answers uh
afterwards happy to answer any question
that's raised on here
my background is primarily Cinema for
over 30 years I've worked in the UK and
internationally laterally with the
European bank for reconstruction
development in places Fairfield is
Kazakhstan open up Cinemas in Taiwan uh
Romania
been working in the Middle East uh
lately primarily where Cinemas are being
built I'm asked to advise and consult
there
in the UK I pretty much spend time from
Inverness to Plymouth with Warner
Brothers I spent a lot of time in London
and my my Journeys journey start off
yesterday in Edinburgh uh through down
through
uh to Newton Abbott uh and I was also
managing director for polo who looked
after the cinnamon paintings so I was
very familiar with Theory at that time
but 10 years ago until it was sold to
view
so in terms of Market overview I'm sure
you've all been reading in the Press
about the the challenges of Hollywood
the challenges of Silicon Valley and
that has an impact on any Cinema
viability in Newton Abbot
last weekend there was a major film
release uh black panthers it's always
talked about in dollars and pounds and
so it was a significant
Blockbuster release the last big one
Black Adam and the one before that Top
Gun
they're really top performing films that
go into Cinema but there's not been
enough of those over the last two years
so since the pandemic started in uh
March 2020
the market in the UK the first year
declined by 76 and then grew back so it
didn't matter where in the world you
where in the UK is fared better than
others Cinemas were closed or shuttered
up
and that set an impact on Market
sentiment from developers investors
landlords who I work with on what
happens next and I've been doing a
multiple local Authority reports
they said that in some instances we're
seeing this isn't suitable
and in others we're saying it's very
suitable they'll come on to Newton
Abbott afterwards
but in terms of the market that part
about Hollywood Netflix Amazon apple and
so is having a big impact and will
continue to do so over the next two to
three years
plays into just in context The Big Three
Cinema operators in the UK which is
around 70 of screens have more debt on
their balance sheets than the entire
Global box office
and that is having an impact and that
was all pre-pandemic levels whereas
smaller family-run independent Cinemas
we've heard about wtw score there's
others in the market they have sustained
because they're long-term players in the
market they don't borrow they don't
raise large levels of debt
and they've been more sustainable
and in terms of say that just going back
to streaming you may also have heard
that I guess Amazon Netflix uh Amazon
Netflix and Apple so they're actually
entering the cinema market and this is
Broad context they see the value of
releasing films into Cinema is a premium
aspect once it's on the library within a
streamer it's invisible it's there for
two or three weeks it's invisible Top
Gun was first released in the 80s it
still resonates now it's got a brand
value and it's it was back this year
it'll be the number one film in the
world this year and it's maintained it's
been brand presence and it enables
customers of all ages all all
populations to go out to cinema
so just in terms of Newton now but
I think this is a very valuable location
for a cinema the proposed location is
dead center in a Marketplace it's got
good access good visibility there's a
nice design around it
one of the pieces we were challenged
with and this is pre-pandemic is that
the average Cinema build was going to be
10 to 12 screens this is four with 650
seats so it's a modest build
the other part that's when we looked
through the occupancy level of the
Alexandra for Cinema screenings that
included some Live Events and others it
was generating over 30 occupancy now
when you compare that to hotel that may
sound low hotels usually work at 80 to
90 occupancy they're selling one bed per
night
this is selling four shows per day in on
a seven day period
so it's obvious that most Cinemas in the
UK track hit us 15 to 17 occupancy
during the pandemic it was down to five
percent in lots of locations so
the numbers generates in Alexandra
suggests that there is a really keen and
active Cinema going uh populace when I
visited the site two challenges that
relate into local community there are
mobility issues with 20 for 20 of the
community in Newton Abba and there is no
ability to go upstairs
for a number of people I given the
staircases and access routes there so
they're pretty much focused on one
screen at the lower level there's also
limited levels of screenings of Live
Events and operas speaking to cinema
management they can't play everything
they would like to so there's a need to
broaden out content and offers and I
would take this from a kids club in the
morning to a live Opera Bali National
Theater so midweek to an entree review
session on a Saturday or Sunday and
special family days so
the other piece and I've not been able
to quantify this and phone but I think
it'd be worth suggesting that this is a
business that we would project to
generate over one million pounds of
Revenue in a year and that's an uplift
from
around 250 300 000 pounds of Revenue it
will enable more jobs I would say a
tripling of jobs in the locality but it
also retains Leisure spend within Newton
Abbot
having done studies elsewhere it can be
up to a 10 additional footfall and 12
additional food and beverage spend in
the air size and no coin effect to other
areas
I also think that it ties into the
Cambridge 10 and we put that into the
report uh some of them are Loosely
termed I think the others are more
closely turned and I'd put this in a six
to nine PM economy opportunity kids
holidays school holidays and other areas
that will benefit from the ability to
have a cinema screening not having
people leave the town and that was again
one of the factors leaving town to go
away to provide to be provided for with
the facility so whether it be Painting
Plymouth Exeter so they should be able
to stay in town more more often and
spend more money locally
could increase the ability for Creative
Services elsewhere but I mean a Cinemas
a cinema but it's up to the operator to
work out what they wish to do
so in terms of viability yes we do see
it's viable at the operational level
the challenge at the moment is the costs
in the market there has been significant
cost inflation
for fixers and fittings so as an example
there is about 30 40 increase in the
cost of a digital projector and there's
a semiconductor shortage globally that's
such as having an impact coming in I
spoke to Scott Cinemas they were
actually waiting on their shipping of
seats to go to Bridgewater
and they were too late in transit but
also delayed because of manufacturing
it's all having an awkward effect
cost of living crisis also has
challenges that will customers be able
to afford to go to cinema as often as
they previously did so we factored that
into economic models
I think the biggest part is that and
this comes back to viability of Newton
Albert it's not straddled with the
impacts of previous it's being built to
a size and scale
potentially that's required now so four
screen 600 seats not 15 streams and 3
000 seats has happened in big cities
there's a growing population here
there's a need to encourage and engage
young people here so when we took all
those factors into account and others we
do see there's a viable opportunity
aspire's operator goes
it's a real challenge for the the
current operator because of timing I've
checked through their balance sheets and
reports they are actually one of I'd say
one of the most sustainable operators
I've seen in Market but their challenge
is not to take too many risks not to put
put their entire company in Jeopardy and
the biggest key was just timing of this
so they're really keen on Newton Abbott
but it's just timing to deliver because
they don't want to jeopardize everything
else they do and they're a very good
company I've known for a number of years
to work with received but and I think
come back to viability
if it wasn't to be wtw Scott Cinemas the
question from me and we've raised this
in the report are there any other
suitable operators out there who would
like to be in Newton Abbot and the
answer to that one is yes there is
it would most likely not be the big
three operators and I couldn't recommend
them because they will most likely
change hands or be in a volatile
situation but there are other
like-minded operators in the market who
have been robust through the pandemic
who would cover it being in Newton Abbot
uh and I'm happy to answer any questions
on the report as as needs
um
no no you sit down yes
it won't hey you on live streaming
thank you Mr chairman very brief
question to the speaker and thanking him
for his address he mentioned robust
other contenders I think was the phrase
um
can he clarify that statement evidence
who they might be
likelihood of participation thank you
like to answer yep so when I'm asked to
do feasibility studies if if uh in most
instances there aren't operators
attached to a specific site or a
development uh so I'd get asked to do
the the feasibility studies and by
default I speak regularly to all of the
operators they provide me with the
information on report they are intending
to do locations that they would like to
be involved in or not
uh so examples that I see in market
right now uh I believe that there's a
the group called it's the arc Cinemas is
one who are heavily active in the the UK
market and growing
they haven't visited the scheme or the
site yet but I I would recommend that an
approach be made there's also Rio
Cinemas who are based in Loughborough
they're very active in Market very
strong balance sheet limited to zero uh
debt or borrowings on the balance sheet
and are very active and Keen to be
working in localized Community Driven
towns so those are two there are there
are another two options that I haven't
uh We've placed into the reports but I
think that they those two would be
definitely most active and interested
others would likely to be more costly
and offered a different type of Cinema
for so
possibilities but that would need I
think it would need to come back to
officers and counselors here to check
councilor McGregor next
thank you chair
um a question again for the um for the
person presenting the report
um
you've just mentioned Loughborough and
one of the key elements I think for
success in a situation like the one
we're discussing would be transport
links which as we know within Devon have
sometimes left a lot to be desired
um with Loughborough Loughborough has
got a great catchment area because it's
got a huge student population looking
for entertainment it's not a hugely
um well-served town in terms of other
facilities but it does have a very large
student population something which
Newton Abbott Lacks
um when I'm looking at transport links
and thinking about particularly
um areas around Newton Abbott
and if you look at tinmouth and dawlish
people have a very good bus service that
comes from Torquay through the town
and up to up to Exeter and they also
have the train service which you know is
very Central
another key element of the issue that I
I see there is a lot of new Cinemas
require parking so if you're going to
increase the capacity of a situation uh
Cinema situation then where are these
people going to park I mean I know that
we have a multi-story car park but we've
reduced reduced parking in the Town
Center by allocating it for a hotel so
from the perspective of what I'm looking
at in terms of Transport links and
looking at parking availability for a
new screen in the center of town I do
find that that is potentially a problem
now coming back to the streaming element
streaming elements really important
my kids all stream they don't really go
to the cinema
um
my my middle son will go to cinema if he
wants to fill himself up on popcorn and
fizzy drinks but that is it
they will mostly wait until it is
available on streaming or they'll pick
it up unfortunately on streaming which
has been
um
delivered early out with the rules so
you know from these perspectives a lot
of children do that
um and and we are going to see more
difficulty in attracting more people to
a cinema location with more screens if
we don't have the feed of the population
coming into the town and that is a
concern for me in in terms of allocating
cash for this
right Council Hocking next please
thank you chair now just a couple of
questions some on the same sort of lines
as Council McGregor actually
um I'm just wondering if the uh the
gentleman from ESS has actually been
into Newton now but it actually looked
where this proposed Cinema is going to
be put or has he just seen it
um by pictures and that sent to him by
this Council
it seems very strange that when you read
through his report there are certain
references to Newton Abbott as a
university
wants to increase it as a University
Town where
It also says that um to access
um the campus Etc where
I am very concerned that um this Council
May well have spent a fair bit of money
on a report that actually they might
have got a better result they bought a
couple of Janet and John books I do not
see Newt Nabbit in this report I am
sorry
the gentleman also quoted the fact that
um
the fact that uh he had um looked at the
figures the people using the scent using
the Alexander
he's but he also put into those figures
this Mike's working is it he also put
into those figures the three weeks that
the uh Alexander is used as a theater
now those three weeks and I can vote for
that those three weeks are always full
that bottom where the Alexander is being
used as a theater is full always has
full houses every day
and yet he's actually brought those into
the cinema figures it would have been
nice if he broke those up and let us
know what the cinema Figures were for
Newton Abbott and I think you'll find
that that will be a lot different than
what he's trying to suggest now Scots
have already admitted that they cannot
make the Alexander pay I really do fail
to see how they're going to make this
brand new four screen 650 seat Cinema
play pay they might have got money now
in their bank accounts but they're not
willing to use it all are they on a
venture they want us to put all money up
front I think we're being robbed we're
being pulled down the line by a company
that actually I don't think will ever
will ever make this new Cinema work it's
a hideous thing being put inside a small
square which is going to make a big big
difference to Newt number is going to
ruin it thank you
thank you chair I think the the points
is working is it yeah I think that the
points that I I wanted to raise of have
more or less been covered I would like
to go back to the parking because we've
heard back from the speaker lots of
advantages of having this Cinema here
um and it's 600 seats and when there's a
Blockbuster movie on it's going to be
packed all day lots of showings but if
you look at 600 people attending a
blockbuster event here then then that
could be 100 or maybe 200 Cars and that
is the concern as to where they're going
to park I don't think we have the
capacity in Newton now but for the
parking
um particularly when you get close to
Christmas time when you've got a job to
park anyway without this Cinema thank
you
this councilor Malone and then I've got
councilor Dewhurst councilman
all right thank you um it it was
um my adopted amendment that uh that
brought you here Mr Arthur and uh and so
I'd like to thank you first of all for
coming all the way from Edinburgh
um
it's a far more effort than Scott
Cinemas have made apparently they have
been asked to present to us uh and have
decided not to do so why on Earth We're
forking out five and a half million to
build them a cinema when they can't even
be bothered to come and present their
ideas to us is beyond me but that's a
mystery I'll probably never get to the
bottom of
um
counselor Hawking has uh questioned uh
ESS and your understanding of this town
um I'm afraid I must uh continue in the
same vein
um
just on the subject of ESS and you'll um
your suitability to assessors and tell
us you know advisors on on on on on on
this decision
um these are some facts in the public
domain so if they're if they're wrong I
do apologize and uh I would ask you to
uh to correct them
um ESS has been in existence for less
than one year and eight months you've
been registered at your current address
for one year and three months
you've got four directors one in
Scotland one in England one in Malta one
in Turkey
uh despite your short term of
incorporation you've changed the details
of your directorship in Residence nine
times
you're currently registered at Mercury
house 19 to 21 Chapel Street Marlow
buckinghamshire this office is a
conversion of a five-bedroom residential
home and with a Chartered Accountants on
the bottom there's five rooms and a
bathroom above the accountants
um there are 86 companies registered to
the five rooms at this address 49 are
active the rest are waiting to be struck
off
you're the director of four companies
none of which have offers premises the
address of two of them is your home
address one is in Beaconsfield the
other's this one uh you've run five
previous companies all now dissolved
through bankruptcy
your last file tax returns shows that
your company's current assets total just
two thousand six hundred and eighty
seven pounds I'm sure you're glad of
this council's business of the other two
companies registered to this home one
Digital Cinema Solutions has an
operating balance of a hundred pounds
the other paguro ideas has declared
assets of 7510 but owes more than twenty
three thousand to its creditors the
fourth company the Leisure property
Forum limited is registered to the
private home in Beaconsfield has no less
than 15 directors and two secretaries
and added six thousand pounds to its
profits last year
there's quite a bit of crossover and
shared family names and addresses among
these directorships now you see what I'm
getting at there's just a few red flags
here there's a company with no track
record operating with the till float of
an ice cream van with a correspondence
address that's an unattended letterbox
in buckinghamshire uh running a company
from your home and you have five
bankrupt companies to your name and it
appears that you're under the cost of
creditors I I'm concerned because you're
advising us on how to spend 5.5 million
pounds of public money when you seem to
have a problem staying in the red
I mean have you even had any clients
before this Council
it just seems bananas to me
that we're accepting what you're saying
is if it's I mean I'm I'm very impressed
by your previous
experience and it sounds like you know
what you're talking about but that kind
of brings me to my second point I asked
for consultation from a disinterested
party
a disinterested party
now your other company the Leisure
property Forum limited describes itself
on LinkedIn as a property-based forum
which offers seminars and networking
opportunities for anyone involved in the
Leisure industry our members include
owners operators developers landlords
agents and advisors I presume of Cinemas
and related businesses now nobody is
going to tell a council that's got five
and a half million pounds of public
money to spend it that their own
industry is not worth investing in
you know the colleagues customers and
business partners uh of you Mr Arthur
our owners and operators of Cinemas and
other entertainment businesses now ESS
is an interested party is there a
question please
yeah the question is what the hell do
you think you're doing I asked in good
faith
for proper
advice from a disinterested party that
understands the nighttime economy not
one that's involved in the nighttime
economy not one that requires the
nighttime economy to be invested in for
the sake of its own members in another
connected company
this is just wrong
this is just wrong and
you've asked a company that does it
doesn't even have a website it doesn't
even have a telephone number they don't
even have a public shop front I don't
know where you found them
this is
you're just pulling people out the ether
and saying these people say we should
spend this money because that's the
result you wanted
and it's just not fair it's not fair on
the people especially right now when
everyone's suffering when everyone's
facing a Christmas of apologies to their
kids instead of Good Will and joy you
want to spend another 600 000 pounds on
this carbuncle on this thing that's
going to be the sarcophagus of this
Administration frankly
and and you found these people to uh to
rubber stamp it for you I'm just
disgusted and my question is how do you
sleep
right if we thank you we heard from you
there at a fairly length
would you like to respond sir yes I
would I
think a lot of the uh the
characterization there is wrong Google
because that's where it all came from
yeah that's fine uh we we are a
relatively new and small company we have
an accountant absolutely there have not
been bankrupt uh the times or so that
impact haven't in the times that have
been raised there I would be happy to
put forward the information who would be
happy to put forward the information
directly on that basis
uh we
we have a number of clients now run run
those through and I've worked in a
number of uh situations prior to this
current business which we established in
a low cost basis during the pandemic
so I have clients in Saudi Arabia and
the UAE aldar is the master developer in
the uh in Abu Dhabi it's one Advanced
Northumberland would be very happy for
you to speak to them we've just recently
completed work for them on the same
basis
of what I've pretty much recently it's
all in the public domain Paisley
Community uh Paisley around Trisha
Council where we where we had to reject
the proposition for a cinema because it
wasn't viable in that area so we are
very objective in our Outlook in a
number of different areas the Leisure
property Forum actually accounts there
are local authorities who are also
members of the Leisure property firm
it's a non-for-profit grouping of people
who work in the Leisure property
industry and that includes landsec
hammerson British land
uh investment companies or so and I was
asked earlier how I can collect or ask
people who would perhaps be interested
in this in this space and that's the
Forum I applied to join and I'm a main
Committee Member
and if actually if the questions are
raised and put into writing I'm happy to
reply to all of them in detail I don't
think it's the guess the right Forum to
to do so but my experience in cinema is
credible and yes I've opened closed
I restructured reopened or so a number
of outlets with challenges
uh it could I come back to some of the
previous points yes you can okay in
terms of say the university uh and so we
we were looking at positive elements in
places there and that's entirely my
fault because I was driving in Newton
and yes I've spent time walking around
here I think it's a really attractive
town in comparison to places that I
otherwise get to visit what actually one
of the most attractive towns that I've
been to
I saw signage for Exeter University and
immediately picked up and there and
checked out the University website and
saw filming media studies there so my
apologies that and we will correct that
in the report
uh in terms of car parking and so yeah
that there's usually between the average
of two to three people who visit uh
visit the town uh well a family or a
couple visiting so there will be
pressures on car parking public
transport or so but it's in the central
Town it makes it more accessible than
other areas uh guess it's like from a
town center first perspective that's
ideal
but me I guess needs to be taken into
account
I'm not sure if there's I guess there's
if there's other points that I guess
apart about four screens part that I was
challenged with in looking through
inviability is that yes it's four
screens it's double the capacity now
but it's more accessible to intensity
disability uh disabled people or others
the 20 people in Newton Abbott who may
not be best able to go into a cinema but
it was the the ability to generate a
30-year lease income that was that I
think was most interesting most
retailers will offer five maximum 10
years so so for a cinema to delivery 25
to 30 view the 25 to 30 year lease
period
was really interesting
I hope that's answered other questions
is that I've got four more counters uh
I'll just read out their names it's
councilor duhurst Council Pullman
councilor Russell councilor Hawking
and you know you can go down uh
counselor patch as well at the on the
end of that that's the door councilor
doors right at the end
okay thank you chair
um I just wanted to say
this this nearly hundred page report to
me
um it is comprehensive
um I wouldn't necessarily expect it to
be absolutely 100 correct in every
single item on a hundred pages
um but for me
if if it looks like a duck it's got
feathers and and swims in the water then
I think it's reasonable to call it a
duck and I think this is a good report
as far as uh the other counselor who's
trying to talk over me uh is concerned
um I'd just like to say in terms of
where this company ESS uh their
registered office is
um I run a tour in caravan Park and our
registered office it is actually in an
office block
um
so we are not
they used to expect and get the right to
be listened to on internet yeah you're
quite right councilman please other
speakers that is not Democratic yes go
on about being Democratic and they're
the least Democratic people in this
place yeah please stop it please let the
speakers speak I allowed counselor
Malone to to in quite a lengthy time to
report on stuff when people were looking
at me and saying should this really be
happening I allowed him that courtesy
and he had what his views it's the right
of every Democratic person here to have
their views listened to uninterrupted
please do that all right yeah carry on
counselor Judas think thank you chair
yes we we seem to be in a world where
those who wish to shout loudest seem to
get heard sadly so as far as I can see
it in terms of why we are here we are
here because this council is being asked
to agree a further 600 000 and this
report is there as a foundation of that
to show where the future of Cinema is
going and as far as I can see it reads
well it does show that we have a a
future here in Newton Abbot I personally
think that is actually a striking design
a modern design and I don't see it as a
carbuncle or anything like that I think
this report shows where it's going as
far as the parking and transport is
concerned
um actually there are lots of
improvements on highways around the town
there is good parking
um you can almost all always find tons
of space in the multi-story which is
well sort of 60 meters from the entrance
to this proposed Cinema and uh as far as
public transport is concerned there are
some fine bus services I think of the
hot 12 which allows people from the
south of the town to come up it's an
incredibly regular service goes right
through into the late nights and
everything that this report talks about
in terms of having a cinema as a base
for a nighttime economy it is going to
going to happen we're seeing lovely
pictures of of of the new market food
halls and the like
I'm not going to comment on Scott
Cinemas because sadly they're not here
today but we have heard that there are
other operators and I'm sure those other
operators would provide the kind of
Cinema
experience that those of us who love
Cinema will enjoy and want to use
thank you
thank you right next councilor was
councilorant
thank you specific questions
um to the report writer do you believe
we have approximately 1 000 car parking
spaces available within three minutes
walk of the proposed Cinema do you
believe a thousand car parking spages
that are free after six o'clock in the
evening are adequate to meet the needs
of potential visitors to the cinema
and secondly in your report the
additional six hundred thousand pounds I
understand is repaid over the 30-year
life of the uh of the project and
therefore it's effectively alone as
opposed to a grant could you please
clarify that thank you
can
particularly confirm both of us Martin
flinkroff will you answer that before us
on behalf of the council yeah thank you
um what we have seen with
um our car parking income since covid is
um
the numbers have gone back up generally
for for car parking income since since
the pandemic
but mainly around Resorts so our our car
parking within our maintained centers
the numbers are still down and I seem to
be staying down so as far as I'm aware
the occupancy availability in terms of
those car Parks is there to help with
this particularly in the evening when
um there are far few people car parking
spaces uh taken up
um it's probably worth me sort of
running through all the the financial
numbers that are contained within the
papers that you've got well while I'm on
the on the subject so
um the cinema itself is going to cost
about eight million pounds ballpark
um we're getting a grant of six million
pounds so it's going to cost two million
pounds to borrow for the cinema
the return is great then the minimum
return after the borrowing has been
repaid
if you look at the wider future High
Street fund scheme itself that's about
13 million and you get 9 million pounds
in Grant and overall including this
extra 600 000 pounds that we're talking
about
the boring is around about 3.8 million
pounds for the whole scheme
outside of that
um there will be an uplift estimated of
our property in and around the
development of around 3.3 million
there's The Wider
economic benefits for around 42 million
pounds to the local economy
and the financial figures that we've
modeled ignore the greater rents that
we'll get for the properties around the
area a few avoids
and the 600 000 pounds that you're
asking or asking for approval for today
um gets added to our borrowing so we
increase our borrowing to 3.8 million
but it's repaid
over the rental period so
um it's not something for free it does
get repaid
um it creates 41 additional jobs
and as we've talked about the start car
parking income will go up as a result of
this thank you
thank you very much uh it's councilor
Russell now
thank you
thank you chairman you will know being
local that this debate is not unfamiliar
to us on the timmouth side of the
Estuary
um we we have a very good now at The
Pavilions we have a very good facility
for Cinema but the Riviera the
auditorium at the Riviera is still there
and is available we use it rotary use it
for charity evening for the for the
African queen and after the Casablanca
and all the old Humphrey Bogart films so
it's still in use like that but of
course it doesn't meet any of the
disability requirements or access
requirements that are provided within a
new facility like The Pavilions and like
this one in Newton Abbott will be so if
you want Nostalgia yes we go to the
Riviera but if you want modern
facilities and modern screenings then
the The Pavilions is the place and the
two go together quite well I I think
possibly the Alexander theater may not
survive the way you know that the things
are progressing but I know how loved it
is for the theater groups and the people
the pantomimes I've been to pantomimes
there and it's a wonderful comfortable
uh theater and I can see the arguments
from both sides I don't know whether the
Consultants have actually got been
familiar with what happened at the
Riviera Cinema because it's Scott
Cinemas the same and they obviously know
very much about the business they seem
very capable and and knowledgeable about
uh Cinema provision in our local area
um but we do have Nostalgia for the
Riviera we go there for charity evenings
but the main I the main features of
course we go to The Pavilions to get the
big screenings and I think that you can
have this in Newton Abbott whether the
Alexander theater survives I hope it
will because it does give Nostalgia
evening things a good go and really
that's all I have to say don't be afraid
of this development because the two go
hand in hand thank you chairman thank
you councilor Russell and now councilor
Hawking
thank you chair for letting me come back
after all I've heard
um being study of this app this morning
I believe that the report from ESS
should be disregarded as I do not
believe it is part it has been looked at
with Newton Abbott in in its mind I
believe it is partly from another Report
with Newton Abbott being fitted in here
and there where the report needs Newton
Abbott to be fitted in I think that we
should disregard this part of the this
part of the meeting and we should
continue now with what we actually come
here to do and that is to discuss the
600 000 pound extra we're now being told
that or or borrowing is now going to go
up to nearly 4 million pound with the
600 000 being added
don't you think that at a time that
we're in at this very moment that to
borrow four million pounds is a bit a
bit of hindsight wrong
we we're waiting for the government to
give their their uh budget today
how much of that budget is going to
affect this Council we do not know it
may well be that we might have to
suddenly find two million pound plus
whole no
um there's pensions going up there's
other things going up wages ourselves
are are continuing to rise
and we do not know what this government
is going to do to the monies that it
passes down to these type of two
councils like ourselves
we are not in a position I do not
believe that to turn around as
willy-nilly and say Here's six hundred
thousand pound more to a company that we
really do not know whether they're going
to say yes we're going to run this
theater or not
um we've we've heard from the
Consultants themselves that says they're
not convinced
if you read between the lines they're
not convinced that Scots are going to
run this Cinema
but they say oh don't worry about it
there's other people out there that will
is that will they
we've got so many unanswered questions
here to suddenly turn around knock half
the market walk down to build and it is
a carbuncle it is a huge building which
which over Shadows a grade two grade one
listed building I.E the market or and
Alexander it overshadows all that it
cannot be if this was anywhere else or
con or conservation officer would have
been jumping up and down saying what do
you think you're trying to do here but
no this is part of tingbridge's own
property so therefore the conservation
officer is actually as far as I know
kept quite quiet
this is not the right place for a forest
green cinema in the center of Newton
Abbott I am not sure where you get the
figures from saying it will increase
increase
um the economy by 42 million pound not
sure where that comes from it'll be
interesting if if it could be explained
how that working out is coming
the car parking
um argument we're all if Queen Street if
Queen Street goes through the way that
Queen Street has been planned and
hopefully it done but if it does all the
cars at Park in Queen Street now on both
side of the road will have to park
somewhere
therefore you will not have the spare
capacity within your car parks and
I'm not sure if I read it right but
you're saying that if these cars then go
and park in the car park the um the
money back the revenue back from the car
Parks will go up does that mean you're
thinking about charging car Parks after
after six o'clock and by the way we
cannot use the multi-story car park
because that shuts at six most of the
people who go to Cinemas go in the
evening which is the idea behind all
this that you want to increase the the
evening economy I am sorry
this is not going to work in Newton
Abbot it is the wrong it is the wrong
place wrong size
and we do not want it yes we want a new
Cinema not there not that size
thank you
um Martin flickroft would like to
respond to uh councilor Mike cocking's
comments
Martin thank you yeah so in terms of the
borrowing
um the returns we get are after the
borrowing so these are positive returns
after we paying the capital of interest
and only borrowing
um the modeling has been looked at
continuously and reflects the latest
position in terms of interest rates and
where we think they're going to go over
the longer period and we do take expert
advice on that the 600 000 isn't given
to the operator it's part of our overall
construction costs and is paid over when
the works have been done by the
contractor to the contractor that's the
way that the deal will be done
um and in terms of our budget Gap yeah I
don't know what the charter is going to
say today
um but we will look at that in the
budget round but these give positive
returns to that budget Gap that we're
talking about
um
I can't tell you where the 42 million
pound figure comes from Apartments it's
around the wider economic develop
development benefits that you get in
terms of visitors using other facilities
in and around the town I imagine but
that's a question for someone else thank
you
right I've got Council of Parrish
Council of doors councilor McGregor
councilor Taylor and councilor con it so
far so we'll go to you know councilor
patch next please
foreign
I'll start by making a sincere apology
for having interrupted a member or two
members today
um born of frustration but it's totally
right it's unacceptable
um and so particularly I apologize to
councilor duhurst for interrupting his
discourse on waterfowl
um I got two very simple questions
um one for the report author and one for
the council
uh perhaps they might want to take a
note and ensure um that they know what
question I'm answering what a question
I'm asking rather and um so they they
can address this correctly firstly for
the report
um
author
um did you visit Newton Abbot prior to
writing the report or your experiences
of driving around Newton Abba or that
are they from after the report was
written submitted for instance in
visiting the council now
exactly for the council
um how did you
um
find
um the um the the consultancy
um outfit for writing this um report
that's put before us now
um I'm just intrigued from hearing from
another member that they don't have um a
website and um any anything putting out
their credentials in this area so I'd
just like to to understand how they were
found in particular with respect to
procurement
um procedures of the council
um for instance were any other bodies
considered
um
42 million yeah it's I find it strange
that um no explanation can be offered as
to where this was found uh perhaps it's
perhaps someone is a Douglas Adams fan
as um the answer to life the universe
and everything was found to be 42.
uh right I think it would take those two
uh questions quickly if you can give it
to Rob Arthur at the back to answer one
that would be handy
so the answer to the question I visited
before or after it was before we were we
were in a relatively tight time frame
from last council meeting to know so I
traveled to the area
stayed in the area for a period of time
went painting new key uh so paint and
turkey Newton Abbot met with Council
officers and walked around the town to
be given guidance and then we looked at
the master plan areas
uh in terms of the other question in
terms of website yes we do have a
website and happy to refer that back to
you afterwards
thank you uh if Neil Blaney perhaps or
Tom Phillips could answers
the other question posed by councilor
patch yeah thank you very much for your
question on the first piece it's a very
niche consultancy market we took advice
from our own advisors Montague Evans who
identified two outfits that could
provide this advice to answer the exam
questions set
um Rob Arthur ESS as we know today he
was appointed appointed and there's
another outfit called The Big Picture
company
and they were both invited to put
forward a proposal in our best to
address
the question including track record
and it went for a selection process
thank you very much councilor Dawes was
next there is a question sorry the third
piece on the 42 million is uh green book
exercise that's quite a prescriptive
government-based assessment of the
economic impact from a development and
that's been undertaken by a freelancer
um
Dominic Chapman who has put forward all
the and it's a appendix to the reports
as well his approach to how that is
assessed and the breakdown of all the
constituent parts
thank you very much
so next appendix four I'm told of the
final report
next to speech was councilor Dawes
thank you uh chair I just seek
clarification where we're at in the
agenda because I've got a fair few
things to say I do have some questions
that are specific to the report so can I
just ask if we will be invited to speak
to the motion for the funding to be
supported by the council uh later in the
agenda as far as I can tell we're still
on item four which is to where the
recommendation is the note the report it
comes up the actual things move on after
we've gone through this one as I see it
but to make me see it differently no no
that's fine I'll keep it brief and try
and keep it to the report then so uh I'd
note the 100 price report is is very
detailed unlike other members I think it
is important that it it it's correct it
did contain a great deal of information
in there uh quite tellingly uh and I'd
invite the rights of the report to
verify this
as I read the report it had Scott
Cinemas Fargo business plan
demonstrating that after five years that
their operation was not viable
and the report writers themselves
suggested that the Scots weren't trying
hard enough and they should do as has
been suggested uh in in the presentation
should should do a few more things
should uh should put on Opera should it
should engage with the community more uh
which running a person who runs a
community uh benefits Society who has
operated Cinemas uh I I'm sort of very
aware that it's very easy for a
consultant to suggest that and uh and
and much harder to to pull out in
practice in normal times uh it's going
to be much more difficult to do this in
uh in in the worst recession in In
Living memory uh so Scots planned
themselves said it was not viable though
they also seem to increase their
customer base uh quadruple it but that's
quadruplet as my talking suggested also
including those sell out three weeks
that the cinema benefits from by running
as a theater which is the buildings of
the use
um so I'd agree with the report
sentiment that it is a good place for a
cinema it's just the scale of the
Cinema's wrong uh and and the ambition
uh is is is unrealistic so the the
business plan that does demonstrate
viability shows a hundred and fifty
thousand customers per year for the
cinema which equates to 417 customers
per day which on current metrics would
be the Alex being sold out twice a day
uh which is quite something uh
population of new number 25
000 so that's every member from North to
100 years old of society coming five or
six times a year I understand
the demographic might stretch Beyond
here so people will uh will be able to
choose not to go to the seventh new 17
screen number in in Torquay and uh and
and travel to Newton now but I just
think it's wholly unrealistic I agree I
was I was going to answer where the 42
million pound comes from uh because uh
it's
um uh it's a standard multiplier that if
you bring nighttime economy into towns
you will benefit them so hence uh
running the the uh the existing Cinema
as a theater will have a benefit running
a cinema will have a benefit and that
number gets larger the more customers
you get so hence hence Consultants who
who put themselves forward for these
jobs uh will try to uh seduce councils
by just increasing the customer base so
the customer base I believe is
unrealistic
so uh the uh the the particular sort of
questions
um are are for the the writers of the
report is um
is I'm I'm a correct in reading that uh
the Scott Cinemas Five-Year Plan that is
contained within the report demonstrates
uh loss making uh business after five
years
uh and um and and how sort of realistic
uh is it to expect
um every member of uh of Newton Abbott
uh to come to cinema six times a year
particularly given we're trading at 75
70 of 2019 uh Cinema occupancy levels
and
um and and the likelihood of streaming
affecting that ongoing is is just huge
it's fine it's not huge it's it's it's a
certainty so so I'll I'll leave any of
my other comments to the later debate
but those those questions remain that uh
that it's wholly unrealistic to uh to
suggest that amount of uh customer base
for a new Full Screen Cinema
well I think in view of what you said
counselors doors I think we ought to
have officers comment on that if one of
the officers could respond to that at
the back I think that would be really
useful
by okay to respond I uh yeah okay so in
terms of just coming back to the the
theater uh revenue and this is the three
weeks of theater the only numbers that
were placed into the Scott Cinemas
accounts as a private higher charge not
the revenue from the theater so that we
we saw accounts for the theater which uh
we we didn't place in as a separate
company separate event but in terms of
say per capita levels I do think there's
challenges in several parts of the UK
Market where I place that when we looked
at the actual numbers for Newton Abbot
and it's it's the county population as
well as Town population
it wasn't unreasonable I give an example
carmarthen in Southwest Wales tracks
it's 16 000 population it's an inland
town uh gravitational to that area when
I opened it up as an operator I'm seeing
this from operator experience 300 000
admits per per year so it's
disproportionate levels of per capita
we actually based this on towns uh Town
population that I was aware of and I
looked at it in reference points but if
you take say terms like Port Tolbert
Barrow rail ashington Northumberland
Washington Northumberland is 15 000
population now it's going through a
similar process to this
it has 16 000 people in town and it has
a lot of competition in the area far
more than here so that that you see it's
always a challenge but we feel we are to
believe that the Newton population
demographic is better proportionally
than the others
uh I think that's actually covered in uh
actually the uh the financials yes uh
the answer to the question is when I
read through the expected outcomes from
Scott Cinemas they were projecting an 11
000 pounds per annum profit when I
looked at the marketing line in terms of
say engagement because post-pandemic and
getting people back into uh getting
people back to cinema engagement those
very little marketing spend in the area
so I projected that they would have to
spend more there which pushed the
balance into a loss and that was running
on about 14 to 15 occupancy I adjusted
on the option two in the report I
adjusted the occupancy by one percent
which increased the admissions by 10
000 admissions per annum which is
nominal but adjusted some of the key
cost lines uh and that's sum up which
was energy and some down film cost and
uh popcorn drinks costs to more
realistic levels and that made a
dramatic difference that moved the
attention moved the payback paid from
114 years which is unrealistic based on
a 30-year lease to six and a half years
based on a 30-year lease on option two
hope that explains the the question
yeah thank you very much you were the
obvious answer to report back when
you're on those questions thank you very
much then we moved to councilman
McGregor now
thank you chair
um Council believe it might be surprised
to hear this but uh he made a very good
point at the last meeting about the
um other elements of the building that
were
you know unallocated in terms of what
they were likely to be
but following on from that excellent
point that councilman made about the
rest of the building other than the
cinema element
um is the fact that having spoken to one
or two Newton Abbot residents one of the
key elements that's come back in all of
the discussions is that beyond the
actual Cinema there's very little to
attract younger people into Newton Abbot
um you know in real terms whilst the
cinema may or may not be a a viable
option longer term we don't know
the economy is currently in free fall
food inflation's up 16.2 percent in
October
um people are already struggling so
we're already talking about within two
or three years as things start to
improve that we're already way further
back than we were when this future High
Street fund
um was allocated in the first instance
so we're we are talking about long-term
viability
it may well be an option that we look at
how that rest of the building is used in
terms of attracting income into the town
not just from the perspective of
bringing in people to spend money in
other nighttime
economy locations like restaurants and
bars and things but actually physically
within that building so that it can be
actually properly viable not just
relying on the cinema operator
and I think that was a key point that
councilor Boulevard made the last time
is that we need to have a clear idea of
the viability of the whole building not
just the cinema relevant element to it
um in terms of the the projection for
the 42 million pounds
again
um as as one of one of my fellow members
pointed out we don't know actually
what's going to be announced today in
the in the budget we don't know how
that's going to impact on local
authorities their ability to borrow in
future
um their ability to pay for services
currently so again it's one of those
very delicate balances of we actually
have to decide
today about whether or not this is a
good scheme for the council to invest in
and I think that is the key element to
it it's not about you know whether we
want a scr you know cinema company in in
Newton Abbot or not or whether we want
to change things or not it's about the
viability of the scheme and that is the
real long-term concern that I have chair
thank you
thank you debate moving along nicely as
I see it because we're only looking to
note this report that we'll get into the
nitty-gritty in the next item but we've
got two more speakers on it as far as I
can see unless anybody else uh we've got
councilor Taylor then we've got
councilor Connor and we've got
councilman loan again
all right I'll I'll take counselor
Taylor uh next if I may we've been
waiting a long time
do you want to come in at the end
next next
uh thank you uh very much chair um I uh
welcome this uh ESS report uh I think
it's a very comprehensive document
um which goes to an impressive level of
detail on current Cinema and events
offers in the in the local area uh from
Exeter in the north to topness Torquay
and Paignton in the South
um I hadn't really thought of about a
cinema being being used to put on uh
events or to or to relay events if you
like
um no matter what happens to the
Alexandra theater we're probably never
going to see the Royal Ballet for
instance come to Newton Abbott to put on
a live performance there but we will be
able to go to a new cinema right next
door and to watch it on screen on screen
there in some very welcoming
surroundings I think there's nobody here
who would who would say that our current
Cinema are offering in Newton Abbott is
of the sort of standard that we would
really like and expect for our town and
I'm very pleased to see the the new
plans for the cinema to come forward
and I and in showing a level of ambition
for the town that I don't think we've
we've we've had before not only that the
the the the the the government funding
that would that would go with an
approval for the scheme at some point in
the future uh we'll we'll really make a
big difference to this town center and I
don't take the view That Others May take
that Newton Abbott doesn't need funding
in in in in to the to the extent that
we've that we've got in front of us here
I think the business plan is good I'm
pleased to see that uh over while the uh
the building will be washing its face
over the next 30 Years that when we come
to that in end point of course it'll be
far more profitable if you'd like it
it's like buying a buy to let property
um and I know there are members here
looking at the register of interests who
do have buy select properties in the
area and if you're buying a buy to let
property but you're also
taking out a uh a loan where you're
repaying your principal and your
interest then you're actually saving up
money for the future uh by uh by paying
by paying off all of your capital and
that that's the sort of business
proposition that we've got here and I'm
also very uh interested to hear about
what our financial officer had to say
about the you know the the side benefits
that would come from it you know the the
additional parking benefits although I
do hope that a lot of people are going
to be using the public transport we've
got a bus hub right next door we've got
very regular services from from the uh
station via the bus although it's not
too far away to walk either we've got a
large town which people can walk down to
the cinema rather than to go out of town
as we've as we've often seen with these
multiplexes elsewhere so so I'm I'm very
pleased to see all all of this offer I'm
pleased that to see the the various
reports that we've had on on on on the
governance side but also you know to
take this higher level view view about
what is happening with Cinema where the
audiences are going to come from what
it's going to help deliver for the town
and at the end of the day the cinema is
in the right place currently the plans
for the cinema are this the site is in
the right place for for the cinema I've
thought about whether there might be a
better site elsewhere but none can
better that this site in terms of what
we're looking at now which is a rather
uh run down if it despite its recent
facelift I I think nobody would argue
that Redevelopment within the market
walk wouldn't be welcome especially the
sort of Redevelopment that would that
would allow a grade two listed building
like the Alexandra theater and the
Market Hall to to be seen uh
in in its proper perspective for the
first time in 50 or 60 years so I I'd be
very much uh happy to to to to
um note this report and to move on to uh
to further discussions but I would also
like to thank ESS for for uh Opening Our
Eyes to what can be and I hope what will
be in in Our Town Center thank you
just
watching do you want to come back on
when I come in first Martin just to pick
up on councilor Hawking's Point um the
conservation officer has taken a
rigorous approach to the application
um it's it's
um untrue that they've not concern
themselves with the application the
Heritage and conservation officers
worked
um very hard on the application with uh
the team who are putting the application
in to make sure that the nature of it is
is improving what's there in terms of
the uh Alexandra because if you look at
the opening up of the area to the side
of it you can see on the on the screen
at the moment
um there's there's opening up of areas
along the side which is removing the uh
the 19 I think it's 80s Edition uh where
the food Hall on the side was put on so
reducing the size of that to open up
more of the context of the building and
also looking at the walkway that would
be between the edge so there has been a
significant amount of input um and I
would suggest that those conversations
have been very robust
because it's a council application not
the other way around which was suggested
which is um it's a council application
therefore you don't concentrate actually
officers offer more diligence because of
the concerns of of comments like
counselor Hocking that there would be
less so so if anything they go
um 101 into making sure that that is
something that's appropriate
um or or mindful so so there has been
some very robust conversations in terms
of finances I'll let Martin answer
yeah just to come back on um cancer
McGregor's observations around borrowing
and what might happen in the budget
today
um
if you approve the extra spend today
there's some Milestones before we get to
construction so you know we've got to go
out to Tender first and if the tender
costs are too high with them we'll come
back to members anyway so
um there's a we're some way off before
we get to that point
um we'll also be spending the government
money first before we borrow so um
that's Point number two and currently we
don't borrow any money at all so we're
in a better position than most
authorities in terms of where we might
be limited to if you like in the future
I don't know whether that will will be
sort of forced upon us at the moment we
operate via a potential code and
potential code
um allows us as a council and you as
members to set that and that happens
every year in the budget process so
that's as as I see it how it will
proceed in the future thank you
thank you very much uh councilor Connor
um thank you chairman as you said this
item is for note uh but I think
everyone's formally moved up but the
conversation has been wide-ranging and
not to preclude conversation on item
five but the purposes of having a motion
I formally moved the recommendation on
agenda item four that we note the
content of the report and I also
formally move the recommendation at five
uh that cancel resolves to approve the
additional capital budget of up to 600
000 in relation to the cinema
construction of fit out costs in order
there for there to be a formal
recommendation for the meeting to
consider thank you
yeah well we'll come to do that in item
five the second bit that you've referred
to really
so you've morphed this one in into item
five as well with a recomme we've got to
have a we've got to have a debate on
item five haven't we generally I wasn't
saying there wouldn't be debate I was
formally moving the recommendation so
it's on the table I accept that I said
I'm alone I'm allowing you to come back
custom McGregor came back so if you can
keep it brief we'll move on to the the
next item where we've had it after the
vote of to note this thank you chair
I'll be as brief as I can um just to
clear up a couple of things uh in reply
to councilor patches question the
officer said that they had two options
the um the ESS or the Big Picture
company
um they're both the same thing for both
spare room operations run by the
gentleman and attendance here the only
difference is that one of them has been
struck off so you can't you can't go to
the big picture company as far as I'm
aware it doesn't exist anymore but hey
get consultation from a struck-off
company why not uh can soak some tea
leaves while you're at it
um a lot of people here sound like they
know what they're talking about but if
you dig into their arguments for five
seconds they collapse they just
completely collapse there isn't a
business case I'd also a little bit
confused by what counselor Dewhurst said
because he seemed to suggest that Scots
are getting cold feet about this and I'd
like to know because he said he seemed
to say well if Scots don't want to take
up this offer then there are others well
who view Cinemas who who've issued
multiple profit warnings uh Sydney world
who whose share price is now worthless
and I'll come back to it to uh to Mr
Arthur's Twitter account because his
tweets are very interesting they they
print they they uh present a far less
Rosy picture of Cinema than he's
presenting to us today I can tell you
and I would I would urge you to go and
have a look at his Twitter account I
mean he says admissions worldwide we're
down 65 in in 2019 and he's he's told us
today that uh that year box office was
less than the Cinema's debts in fact uh
worldwide uh Cinemas incurred deaths of
26.9 billion US Dollars year on year
five percent of Cinemas close
five percent of them close
year on year and he makes very very
clear because he put He prints a graph
of the two publicly traded Cinema
companies in this country cineworld
versus every man and points out the
difference between them cineworld is
bankrupt pretty much
uh whereas every man is still going and
that's what he means that's what he
means when he says it could work if it
is an audience focused Community
centered venue because he means that's
the exact same phrase he uses to
describe Every Man's Cinemas now these
are Cinemas that have parties events hen
nights Rocky Horror Picture shows that
sort of thing they have a very loyal uh
following they they chase every pound
and they're in the middle of the
community and they're small and they're
in City centers and it is a completely
completely different business model to
the one that we're being asked to
approve which is Scott Cinemas which is
a passive Big Ticket Hollywood Cinema
industry and if you look at Mr Arthur's
Twitter he says over and over again that
this business is pretty much defunct
by his own words and and he has a
colleague I think from Curzon Cinemas
Philip Mordecai and he says the the
bricks and mortar model of traditional
Cinema is in for more pain and
contraction in 2023
this is the Scott Cinema model
the people that are advising you to
build it have said
that it's finished it doesn't identify a
single part in the world where where
Cinema is doing well so why the hell is
it going to do well in Newton Abbott in
a small Market town in the middle of the
worst recession we've ever faced
thank you thank you well we need a break
very shortly I'd like to to we've had a
motion to move the report this will all
come out I mean in the next item item
five where have it so can I have a show
of hands be I think purely that we just
note this report and this will go into
debate in the next item as I see it is
that acceptable to your can I show have
a show of hands for the motion which was
to note the report
you've got plenty of opportunity in the
next item to will fit out
yeah
it's a bit late it's a bit late now
there's nothing contentious in noting
the actual report is and it goes into
debating the next item so so those that
are against noting the report should
please show we've noted the report let's
have an adjournment uh a comfort break
now for 10 minutes can we just do this
sorry can we just vote to know your
report because can we vote to note the
report I'm being told
foreign
against
and extensions
right it's carried and denote the report
right let's have a break for 10 minutes
and then we'll come back and get on with
the meeting for item five
yep
we moved to item five now
uh in the agenda
and we've had a a proposal and a second
for the recommendation
which is uh to approve the additional
capital budget of up to 600 000 in
relation to the cinema construction and
fit out costs and that was uh proposed
by Alan Collett and seconded by
councilor Alistair Dewhurst so it's now
open to debate
now I hope members
debated most of it in part one obviously
there'll be plenty more to be said I
suspect but I don't want people going
over stuff please that you've already
said in in the previous item but uh yes
councilor perch your first of speech
first to speak
thank you chair uh just a question on
process for this we've got item
um five which are on now
um item seven which will be in part two
um and then item nine which all seem to
be interrelated and the same issue
essentially
um when will we be making the
substantive vote on this or will it be
under item nine as I understand it
no item item five is a standalone item
and as I see it and we've had it
proposed and seconded that that this uh
be done so it's now open to debate uh we
probably won't need to go into part two
here uh because I think
that that won't occur obviously if
there's a feeling that you want to take
the debate into part two then uh I can
do so uh if the members request me to do
so okay so the substantive decision on
the funding will be made before we get
to item nine
um I'm not sure what is the point of
item nine in that case
well
would you would you like to answer that
in in perhaps a more professional way
than I am it's going through the
business case Etc isn't it I would think
the business case must be discussed
before we make the decision on it
the managing director wants to speak on
this obviously
the agenda's been laid out the way it is
so
thank you
it's with you really chairman in the
sense that if you want to move to part
two if members want to discuss the
papers uh in Pages 123 to 132
um that's what we were suggesting were
the you know the the commercially
sensitive papers then we can do that and
then come back
um it's a matter for you as a committee
whether you want to move into part two
or whether you deal with it when we put
the agenda together we did consider
whether we needed uh or you know whether
it was relevant to go into part two and
and you know there was a question about
we might not need to go into part two
depending on how the meeting was and
what you wanted from that so it's a
decision really for for members and to
determine whether they want to move with
respect chair that's not the question I
asked um I'm asking what's the point of
having item nine discussing the revised
business case for the future High Street
fund project after we've made the
substantive decision on the extra
funding
uh Neil blaney's put his hand up at the
back so I think we ought to hear from
Neil
uh thank you chair
um the running order of the um agenda
today follows the decisions from the
notice of motion and then the Deferred
decision in September on the additional
funding
um so the notice of motion relates to
item nine which was the revised
proposals relating to the Market Hall in
the Alexandra Cinema
um and then any of the changes to the
plan
um item five is about the six hundred
thousand pounds additional budget for
the cinema element of the project so
what we've done is we've set out the
agenda to have the audit and the cinema
review that was asked from the 6th of
September
um we then come back to that decision
um subjective members agree on that
we've then got to go back to government
with the revised business case which
shows
um the revised plans for
um the Alex and the Market Hall
um but what we're saying is if the 600k
isn't signed off
that part of the scheme doesn't happen
and it changes the business case anyway
so there's a chronology of the decisions
that need to be made and if you make the
decision to agree or not the revised
business case
um the 600k if it's not accepted falls
off so it's it's the first one is about
the additional budget for the cinema and
then it's the final business case that
we would resubmit to government to look
at the revised of the plans and ask for
an extension of time
right his hands going up at the back
again Council patch thank you chair
um
it still seems to me we're putting the
cart before the horse here
um hello
it's got to be quiet here
um I still don't see how we can make a
decision on the extra funding without
having discussed the business case
revised business case there's a danger
surely that if we don't just discuss the
business case this Council will make a
decision
and then discuss a way of justifying
that and rewriting rewriting the
business case to account for the
decision I think and as long as we are
able to just discuss all domain facts
before making the decision
um that that's my main concern really
so I I would would hope that we can
discuss the business case before making
any decision on the extra funding
well you've heard what the officers have
had to say I'm content to let the let
the uh
and as I'm in the chair let the decision
continue here we're on item six and
we've had a proposed item five and we've
had a a proposal and a second there for
the case
all right to spend this money so I'm
continuing with that I'm afraid
uh I now do members want to move this
into part two or not
there's no desire to move it into part
two right so I'll take General debate on
on
um this item
I've got counselor doors first
sorry
now yes
cancel the doors your first to speak
thank you my microphones now on so so
yes taking on board your uh the decision
to continue with the debate uh I'll now
focus on the the question at hand
um I noted from my questions to the
consultancy uh that uh they did they did
include the uh uh theater uh hire fee in
in uh in Scott's Cinema's income uh and
they also said that they'd added 10 000
people to the Scots own plan for the
larger Cinema to make you viable uh oh
to be a consultant uh to be able to add
10 000 customers at a uh a stroke of a
stroke of a button so the that brings us
to the 150 000 customers and the 42
million pound multiplier for the the
town uh just to give us some context on
that Austin's turnover uh published
turnover is six million pounds per year
so we're talking about uh seven uh the
impact of having seven Austin's
department stores uh put onto the town
by having a cinema that that could in
today's terms sell out the Alexis
current capacity twice a day every day
365 year uh days of the year I I just
think that's that's unrealistic uh like
uh councilor Malone but uh using
different routes I also
thought that originally we were going to
get one of the big four uh accountancy
firms to look at this to give their
um
unbridled conservative with the small
City View on on the viability of this uh
but also to put their Pi there their
their professional Indemnity and their
reputations uh behind this
um when I asked a top industry Insider
why uh what who the best people to
consult on this would be and why the
council hadn't in their opinion
appointed one of the big four they said
the the accountancy firms are too busy
in this sector with total distress and
decimation of the industry uh the the
the the other the other points I asked
my industry Insider was to form an
opinion on uh on the Consultants who
were appointed they said they didn't
know them but they knew of a company
called The Big Picture company who have
a Playbook that uh flaky but very good
at going around and squeezing money out
of councils then when they looked at the
Personnel on company's house they
realized there was a crossover between
the Big Picture company and our current
Consultants so uh so the red flag and uh
alarm bells ringing there for me
um the the there are things in the
report that I and other people in the
town would agree with and other people
in the creative sector would agree with
uh the town does need the cinema that
site in itself is not an unreasonable
sight for us in fact very convenient
right next to uh the Alexa grade 2
listed theater uh what's wrong with the
current plan is the scale of it uh the
ambition is is totally unrealistic in
the current uh in the current markets uh
the report writers are correct in saying
that you need someone like the every man
of Scots are a good operator but they've
put down what they said is viable and uh
and they they they had to have their
figures massaged for it to work what you
need is a community-led cultural offer
within the city and yes every man would
be great Scots can do what they can do
um
and uh and and I think what what is
likely to happen is that we will end up
with a community-led uh uh uh sort of
initiative within within this sector
because the other thing that's included
in the report which I hope everyone's
reading detail is the project plan uh
which which demonstrates that all of the
money from the future High Street funds
needs to have been spent by March 2024
so there is there is no scope for delay
uh this project has to start tomorrow
planning has to be passed without delay
there has to be no challenges has to be
no inflation there has to be no
contractors
procurement problems uh here's an
example of the council's ability to deal
with change and ability to manage live
large-scale building projects we've been
sat in this uh this temporary Council
chamber for I don't know how many months
we don't have a council chamber due to
unforeseen circumstances stances
so I suggest that the future High Street
fund whatever is debated today is is is
is is doomed uh the the lack of
Engagement with the
with the community groups uh being the
biggest failing there uh what is put
forward in the plan is not is not
achievable
and uh What the residents of teambridge
need at this point in time uh is is some
realism and and not for people to be
playing faster loose with their money my
question to people in this chamber is if
this was your money if this was your
pension your 600 000 pounds or a hundred
thousand pound pension two hundred
thousand pound pension would you be
putting this money your own money into
this uh I certainly wouldn't be doing
and I wouldn't like to do it on behalf
of the residents of teambridge either I
think we will be able to drag something
out of this but uh unfortunately the the
competency of the project to date has
been failed uh been failing and uh and
uh I urge members not to take a reckless
decision to uh to to to support this
motion thank you
now sir Wilson
thank you chairman a couple of things
I'm trying to keep an open mind as much
as I can but in general I think we're
such a good quality information and a
good quality audit report uh on the
process and I think some of the
arguments against now and the attempt to
undermine the quality of the information
is a bit worrying for example we hear
the 400 seats a day that's twice the
Alex theater as it currently is to be
filled every day and that sounds uh not
credible but what we're not being told
is of course we've just got four trees
so that 400 a day becomes a hundred in
each screen and if it's Four showings a
day that's 25 seats in the screen that
feels very credible information and I
think it's all about how you present
this and when we say we haven't had
engagement and all the other things the
independent Auditors have actually said
yes we have and the officers have done a
great job so I just want to put some
balance into this when we look at the
information that's being challenged and
especially at the way it's being
challenged at the moment thank you Kim
it's councilor Connor next
Carson McGregor and after okay can you
capture the eyes for me
thank you thank you chairman I'll stick
with most of my points into uh this
section rather than in section four
I found it very interesting that the
council's gone out after the
um adjournment of the last meeting the
amendment that was carried and
commercial reports from Devon audit
partnership and then from ESS
and that's enabled people who take issue
with the ESS report to look at the
consultant and their Bona fides and say
what they say
but council is invited to accept
a top industry Insider
without knowing who that is or what
their Bona fides are for us to check who
they are and what they know and what
their credentials are in terms of
evaluating that but we're invited to
accept that councilor Dawes has spoken
to top industry Insider and we should
accept that with the same weight as the
consultant who stood at the back of the
room and talked about his industry
experience and what he's done
this is though a decision right now in
terms of the up to six hundred thousand
pounds additional investment in a cinema
I think there are two Divergent views in
this room
there are most people who have a view
about Newton Abbott as a market town
which is fine as it is and needs a
little change if any change at all
and there's a view a different view a
view that I share which is Newton Abbott
has underplayed its place in Devon if
not the region but certainly Devon for
too long and we have an opportunity here
to invest
not only our own money but uh the
government's money through 9 million and
before anyone says it I do appreciate
governments don't have money on their
own it's taxpayers money and I accept
what councilor Dawes says that this is
public money whether it's coming from
Team mature from government
but the important thing about that is
your vision for Newton Abbott and who
it's serving is it just for people who
live in Newton Abbott to go to the
cinema or is it conceivable that people
in Bobby Tracy might like an evening out
instead of going to Exeter they go to
Newton Abbott people in starcross are
also on the train station might come to
Newton Abbott rather than going into
Exeter that people further up in the
north of teambridge might actually drive
down to Newton Abbot and enjoy a really
good night out in the town and that
boost our economy and reference was made
to car parking so let me be clear in the
forthcoming Council budget we have no
intention no plans no desire will not be
suggesting to council charging after 6
pm and in fact I'll even go further I
would be happy to include in the budget
proposals that this cancer makes a
commitment not to do that for the next
four years because it's the nighttime
economy that we particularly want to
boost it's all about getting more
footfall in
and it strikes me that the point made by
councilor Hocking is actually a value
point but actually if we're a council
that is saying we want to boost in that
kind of economy I I'm grateful to him
for the idea that we might charge after
six but it's not one that we had
entertained or thought of and I don't
think we should do that in terms of the
multi-story car park FS extra capacity
needed then the council at that time can
choose to open up the car park if it
needs to
but the important thing is also that
we're not making a decision today
because the cinema is going to open
tomorrow we're making the decision today
on whether to invest up to six hundred
thousand pounds subject to having a
signed up Cinema operator with us
whether that's wtw Scots or a another
and the Consultants set out the type of
region operator that might be interested
in coming to Newton Abbot so there are
safety
catches within the decision
up to six hundred thousand which has two
Finance officers indicated is to be paid
back
no spending without a signed up Cinema
operator with us
and then we are talking about about a
two and a half three year period of time
so I quite understand the anxieties
right now about the recession that the
country is facing and the difficult
climate
but some people would say some people
would say that now is the time to invest
so you're there to ride the wave when
when the economy recovers
there are some people who would say well
will it ever but it has in the past and
I'm convinced that the UK and Newton
Abbot will see better times
that Newton Abbott is not going to see
better times if his own Council won't
invest and for many many years local
government not just teambridge but many
councils have been the people who
invested then the private sector
wouldn't
it's the local government the municipal
sector which has taken the risk of
investing
in order to make things happen to
protect jobs which is one of the things
that we want to do protect and retain
jobs to boost our economy to support our
businesses to get more independent
retailers into Newton Abbott and support
our town these are fine Ambitions which
are sometimes lost in the conversation
simply about the cinema chairman
my view my vision is a vision for Newton
Abbott and for teambridge that's why I'm
going to support it as a counselor for
Kenton with Star Cross is because I
think this is the right thing to do for
the district which supports people in
their everyday lives by giving an
opportunity for young people to come
into town have somewhere to go people
who may want to go out for a meal before
or after and see a cinema and I think
councilor rollerson neatly unpicked the
challenge that we were being given about
whether this was a full theater a full
Cinema twice a day every day to actually
breaking it down into what it means on a
full Screen Cinema
so chairman
I happily moved the recommendation on
this agenda because I think it's the
right thing to do it's not without its
risks but whatever else is in life
walking across the road has a risk for
this council with the nine so million of
government funding into the future High
Street fund we have an opportunity for
Newton Abbott but let's not lose sight
also but if we don't do the cinema if a
vote fails today we don't do the cinema
there then may be no change at the Alex
the opportunity for a cultural and arts
center goes because the cinema stays
there
we don't know what WT Scots might want
to do in time those things are uncertain
so what we throw is throw Newton Abbott
back into a recession at a point when we
are trying to pull it forward to make it
some place where people will want to
come and make some Positive Choices
about
I think that's a goal in ambition which
is worthy of this Council and I would
ask councilors to support it Shannon
thank you very much
thank you councilor McGregor next and
Phil
patch
thank you chair
um I when I put my hand up earlier it
was actually just to amend the motion
slightly to call it an in-principle
acceptance of the um up to six hundred
thousand pound additional cost
however um having listened to councilor
con it
um making his impassioned plea for for
the expenditure in in Newton Abbott
there are one or two elements that kind
of sort of leap out in terms of of the
longer term view for Newton Abbott once
a long time ago I was um executive
member for sport Leisure and Recreation
and during that time we were talking
about the fact that Newton needed
additional Leisure facilities
that the swimming pool was inadequate
for the the demand that was already in
place that we were sharing facilities
with with the school
um and that we were we would be looking
at a replacement Leisure Center so
where's that going to go within the
Newton Abbot
um development if we are saying that
we're going to commit to retaining the
Thousand car parking spaces that we've
currently got because that
new Leisure Center is going to take up a
fair amount of space whichever way you
look at it but in principle
I think what we we should be doing is we
should be saying that if the business
case review that we're about to take in
the part two
is is to be discussed in full and
debated in full then I think in in
principle we can move to approve
um so I I would I would back that that
motion at the moment on an in-principle
basis thank you okay
it's Council the patch and then it's
Council of bulovan
all right
thank you thank you
I found it interesting that um the
leader when attempting to broaden the
appeal of a new large Cinema
um chose to First mention Bobby Tracy
um as as a sort of community for pulling
in people to the cinema in Newton Abbot
perhaps he's unaware the people of Bobby
Tracy have for some time being pulling
together a community-funded initiative
of a local Cinema in Bubby Tracy which
operates not just as a cinema
incidentally but also as an art gallery
we'll have a cafe in there
um
the people of public trading can be well
served
um
I speak also from my experience of
arranging for several years now a
community Cinema in liverton Village
Hall
we we put on films that we we think will
appeal to local people and we do get you
know a few a few people the numbers vary
month on month
um who come along to watch the carefully
chosen films we put on we've never made
a surplus we can't make a profit we're a
charity we've never broke even I don't
think we've ever come close to breaking
even that's fine we're a charity we're
charged with we're putting on our
Provisions for the community
I think I think if people certainly in
my area want to go and see a film at a
cinema rather than sit at home and watch
it streamed they've got options
available I don't think well I mean
perhaps someone one of the members here
that represents Bobby Tracy can tell us
about the the plans and vision of um the
Bobby Tracy Community for that Cinema
and um how that's going
um if it fails
the the the the the sort of the project
and Bobby Tracy then that sends a signal
larger grander scales scale projects
won't succeed if it succeeds that will
be at the expense of what is proposed
for a centralized Cinema
um
I I have a fear here that this is doomed
to failure what regardless of whether we
vote to commit 600 000
um I think the economic circumstances
the lack of a vision in terms of
pitching
um what might work and I know this is a
a view that is shared by others in this
room
um I'm not sure this will actually
happen it will not happen as a project
um I think the travesty of this is that
for a couple of years there have been a
small number of members with industry
experience who have been putting forward
the view that this whole project should
have been reconsidered to something more
modest more tied into the community
um that might have allowed us to take
this huge tranche of the money to
benefit Newton Abbot and indeed the
local surrounding areas
it's on record over the last two years
the votes where people have voted
against the suggestions that we have
been making in order to in effect push
it into long grass to bring us to a
stage now where the time has run out the
clocks stop ticking I I I personally
think um there's very little chance even
if we vote through the money now that
this will be provided and indeed be or
if it's provided will be viable in six
eight ten years time and and a lot of
council taxpayers money would have been
put towards it perhaps I'm wrong I hope
I'm wrong I hope if it's voted through
it succeeds
I think we're discussing the wrong issue
today I think what we should be
discussing is can anything be salvaged
from this car crash of of a of a project
there's a lot of money that was an offer
offer for Newton Abbott if the
leadership of this Council had listened
to local people in the community to
members of this council with industry
experience people with creative ideas
then we might be discussing a totally
different project now or it would have
been given a green light by now
as I said this is all on the record when
it when it comes to be told
people will be accountable not just the
leadership who refused to listen to the
people of Newton Abbot and and the
independent-minded members of this
Council but I think the record will show
because of much of the voting we managed
to get recorded votes the recording will
show how the the party members
the the liberal Democratic conservative
or The Condemned Alliance as I like to
call them how they supinely just voted
along with what was put in front of them
and did not question what what was going
on here
it's a real shame that it's the
independent members of this Council that
have tried to get this on track
and I I just yeah but I think I've I've
made my views on this matter
um I'm not going to vote um for it I
don't think I think it would take a lot
to persuade me that um we should throw
good money after bad
thank you
uh Beatrice councilor Boulevard
thank you
um first of all can I just say the
comments made by councilor Connors I
totally endorse and I think is he's a
view of this application is is the right
one
I am concerned that
since 19 or since 2019 or 2018 when the
first
proposals came forward for the future
High Street fund they were based on the
fact that it was recognized across the
country High streets in small towns were
declining and town centers were
suffering because of it
and the policy that came forward was
Town centers needed a vision
an idea of how they could invest to
promote those Town centers to bring life
back into the town centers
and the future High Street fund and the
funding that was allocated to Newton
Abbott came forward because a vision of
what could be happening could be
delivered
in requirements to make the
um football increase visitors to town
bring life back into the center of
Newton Abbot now as a Newton Abbot
resident and very proud new Nabbit
resident
I recognize the fact that our town needs
investment
the funds that are coming forward are
essential to the Future well-being of
our town
the proposals to put a cinema
are the only proposals that have been
seriously put on the table for two years
we've heard from the friends of the Alex
and other people who've got a legitimate
interest in bringing other
activities into the town to create a
cultural center but we're still waiting
two years down the line for proposals
from them how the old Alex
center of the building can be used and
converted as far as I'm aware I haven't
seen any Financial proposals or ideas
that have
come forward for anybody to consider
we need to take a forward view we need
to promote Newton now but we need to
recognize that the town needs investment
this is a vehicle for us to be able to
do that
in making this decision and I'd remind
people it's
money to be invested to be repaid over a
period of lease it's not a grant
I think this is essential for the future
well-being of Newton Abbott and
particularly the two most deprived areas
or two of the most deprived areas in the
whole of Devon which on the doorsteps of
this Cinema it'll bring employment and
jobs and opportunities for those people
that are currently at the bottom end of
the social spectrum and we need that I
ask counselors to recognize for the
benefit of Newton Abbott this is a good
investment it's a good idea for the town
and I ask you to support the idea that
we can do it we'll be coming on to how
we can support the idea of the creation
of the art center within the Alex
building and again that's something
that's good idea but we need to look at
it in I think section 9 of this meeting
so please I ask you to on behalf of the
people of Newton Abbot please support
the town getting an up-to-date modern
facility that'll bring people to our
town thank you
thank you uh it's now councilor Taylor
um
thank you very much chair
um
as a member for dawlish
um I don't think it's really
um my place
to say no Newton Abbott can't have this
money for a new Cinema
um similarly
I'm surprised that councilor patch is
proposing that he couldn't support this
because oh not similarly
taking the completely different view to
councilor patch who is saying that but
that because Bobby Tracy has its own
facilities and because ilsington also
has them then that he couldn't support
this cinema this Cinema is of the type
of Cinema that reaches out Beyond Newton
Abbot it attracts people from from far
and wide dawlish has its own uh small
theater with Cinema
um it's a very nice provision to have
but if I want to go and see Top Gun or
the latest Bond film I wouldn't want to
go and see it at the shaft spray for all
it's for all its uh quaint charm
one of the main main reasons is the
seats aren't very comfortable and that's
something that that Scott Cinemas has
been careful to do in its own offer it
has some of the most comfortable seats
in in the in the district and attracts
other members from from dawlish and I
know from from tinmouth too where there
has been mention about the seats uh also
in The Pavilions but it's but
comparisons are odious I certainly will
be supporting this uh this uh extra 600
000 whether it's for Scott Cinemas Who
currently are probably looking and
Counting the beans to make sure it's to
see whether they can afford to to move
ahead with us or to another provider
who's probably looking at this extra 600
000 thinking actually that'll be very
nice you know we could really make a go
of this in in Newton Abbott and perhaps
bring those other event uh type of uh
um displays that that would that would
also boost footfall in the in the Town
Center so I would certainly be
supporting this and uh I hope that other
members will do also thank you
point of a reply which I'll be
misrepresented
did you want to speak to tell us why
you've been misrepresentative
yes yes chair I'd like to point a reply
and I've been misrepresented by
councilor Taylor in his last response I
did not say that I'd be minded to vote
against this proposal for the extra
money because Bobby Tracy and other
places have facilities and by the way I
mentioned liverton Village Hall or
ilsington
um I suggested I would be minded to vote
against it because I don't think it's
viable I I think it there's a real
overwhelming danger that it will not be
working that money that Council
taxpayers are put towards this already
yeah I have yes to put that's that's
what I said not the misrepresentation
just to correct it thank you thank you
very much
uh right it's Council Malone next to you
now
thank you yeah there's an awful lot of
straw man arguments being put forward
here councilor patch didn't say that
because Bobby trophies Chase has got a
Cinema Newton Abbott shouldn't have one
nobody said to contradict councilor do
you hearse that some people think Newton
Abbott doesn't need investment nobody
has said that and to contradict
councilor Connor nobody has said that
some people think Newton Abbott should
just chug along as it is nobody is
saying that can people please stop
reconstructing our arguments to mean
that we want to live in the past in the
Dark Ages and we want Newton Abbott to
stay the same and preserved in aspect
nobody has said that once okay all we've
said all along is not this
not this we've said and we've been
ignored all along so now we're here
still saying not this and like counselor
doors I thought I honestly thought in
good faith when I asked for that
amendment that you were going to go to
one of the big four consultancies and
just look at Cold Hard monetary facts
just financials
I I didn't think you were going to go
off to some Cowboy outfit that's been
established for five minutes because
because I tell you when when they Mosey
off into the sunset
there's gonna be nothing left there's
going to be no accountability they're
just going to liquidate that company and
start another one like they have done
nine times already
this is not a consultation you're
pulling figures out the air you're
pulling people out the air you're
working to fantasies
you're like children it's just insane
what you're proposing
and when you will be held accountable
for this mess
because I agree with councilor con it
actually I think Newton Abba isn't
pulling its way in in Devon I think it
should be doing a lot better and the
reason for that is because it's been
done over by Council after council with
bad decisions from pen in and the
roundabout and Sainsbury's to Asda and
it's 16 Acres of car park this town has
been ruined by Council after Council
sitting in this chamber making crap
decisions and this isn't an antidote to
that this is very much in that tradition
ruining Newton Abbott with this
monstrous lump of metal that does not
fit in that I haven't heard a single
people single person outside this
chamber say they like
I I'll make a prediction right this
either will never happen or it will be
closed down or repurposed within five
years of opening and I will give anyone
who wants to bet with me evens on that
yeah can put your money where your mouth
is let's have a bet on this put your own
money into this
that thing is not going to last
I'll I've let you let you have your say
counselor Malone and you feel the way
you do and you speak passionately and
you've had your say so I think councilor
Jules would like a write a reply to that
from what I can see counselor Dewhurst
thank you chair to be quite honest I I
think councilman should apologize to a
guest who is here uh who who doesn't
have the same kind of writer's reply as
we counselors do I think it's appalling
Behavior
could you tell me what I said that was
factually incorrect which I was a child
I'm only 60 years of age
okay come on members now don't say I'm
giving everybody the right of uh Speech
and everything so it looks like Duck
[ __ ]
let's let's move on please it's
councilor Hocking now I think wants to
have a say
foreign
[Music]
um
I uh obviously you all know my feelings
on on this
um I am dead against us spending another
100 600 000. on this building
this building is not wanted
yes a cinema is and we've been no no
qualms about that even when you went
back to 2018 when the High Street and
there's been many many meetings over the
past many many plans have come forward
the cinema has been put Here There and
Everywhere
um and in between that this Council paid
13.2 million for Market walk
um in the in telling us then that they
were going to get all the money back
from that 13.2 million over a short
period of time through the rents and
whatever you and then find yourself
hoping to spend another hundred thousand
to buy the post office out which by the
way is still empty we still have empty
shops within Market walk which is time
which is Council doesn't seem to want to
rent out
um I know when they bought the place
they bought the market what they said
they wanted to keep heart high quality
shops within within the Town Center
well that's not happened does it because
you still got empty shops there which
are not being rented out
so you're obvious this council is
obviously losing money that pla in in
that you are now going to knock down two
shops to put this new Cinema in one of
them is um new look
not sure where they're going to go are
they going to stay in the town it would
be nice to know because that is a
well-used shop
um shawls which was there has been empty
for good nozzles how long and has never
been rented out presumably for the same
reason that
um the uh the post office hasn't been
rented out that this Council has other
plans for it and obviously shows the
other plans is the fact they're going to
knock it down and put this building up
this building is too big
people do not want a whole huge building
that holds four screens
it could be half the size and still have
four screens it could have two screens
on the ground floor two screens on the
top floor it could be cut down to two
screens on the top floor and still have
your and still have your retail
underneath
but are we going to be in the same
position as we have been for last
few years since tingbridge bought the
boat Market walk and still have empty
shops underneath her still not being
able to rent them out because we can't
find the high quality shops that this
Council believes they should have in
there
or are we just going to put
um some more um takeaways in there or or
whatever yes we could do with more
restaurants but actually Newton Abbott
has got quite a few very good
restaurants all privately owned very
good restaurants I do not see and I've
lived in Newton Abbott for the last
since I was born basically admittedly
for the first 20 years I lived in
Kingston but Newton Abbott has always
been the town King Staton has always
been a village and as far as I can see
still is but that's another another
argument
the town itself is vibrant
we are trying some people in this room
are trying to paint the picture that is
not the tone is vibrant we have we have
one mainstream store of Austin's even
the owner of Austin's doesn't believe
that this is the right thing to do
within Newton Abbott
now if he thought he was going to gain
all this extra footfall surely he would
be supporting it but no he don't he's
against it
and why because he does not as a
businessman he does not see it working
and I am afraid that we could if we're
not very very careful we could put
another six hundred thousand however you
however you uh match it up whether it's
a loan or whether it's it'll come back
in 30 years time because we'll get it
back through the rent is immaterial we
at this moment in time we are going to
commit ourselves to just under 4 million
pound of borrowing to do what people in
Newton Abbott do not want yes they want
a cinema they don't want that and they
don't want it that size please let's
start being realistic either cut it down
and make it look a bit better
but don't put a bump put a shipping
container on top of two shops and put it
next door to a grade two listed building
thank you
thank you does the officers are wanting
to reply to this so I'll let you carry
on
yeah so I just wanted to clarify the
situation on Market walk since we bought
it
um
when we did the business case for Market
walk we assumed a minimum return that we
required from that investment
as I understand it and we look at the
budget every day that return is still
being made above that business case
minimum
in addition to that when we took it over
the number of units that were unless at
that point
um is more than what it is now so we
have let more units since we first
purchased that building thank you
incredible answer isn't it thank you uh
right it's Council doors to speak then
councilor Cox
hi thanks for letting me come back I've
got three points I'd just like to come
back on that have been mentioned uh
one was the suggestion that if this
doesn't happen that the there's the
likelihood of no change at the Alex so
Scott Cinemas continuing to operate
there uh we've been told multiple times
uh that Scott's uh Scott Cinemas don't
uh see the current operation as viable
so I'm not entirely sure which one it is
are they going to stay there or or is it
not viable this is why we have to do
this
um the suggestion that uh assued the
people in here or a small number of
people in here want to keep Newton
Abbott as it is is very disingenuous I
mean we spent half an hour debating
whether I could even speak on this
matter I mean are people not noticed
that there are plans for the Alexandra
theater they've been drawn up by a group
of committed individuals have people not
noticed that the 43 members of a
cultural group that has been set up in
the absence of this Council having a
cultural strategy like any other
grown-up Council would have uh I'm
slightly disappointed in councilor bull
events suggesting that because there's
no business plan for the Alexandra
theater Community benefit Society
therefore is not viable he knows it's
been frozen out and uh disengaged by
this Council he also knows that that
cancer that that Community benefits
Society has been successful in gaining
architectural Heritage fund grants
for development of the business plan we
have got government uh not government
we've got National support from the
architectural Heritage fund to develop
the plan so please don't say that
there's a lack of ambition and lack of
Engagement and no other Solutions and
suggestions in terms of a reality check
let's just go about counselor Hawking
brought forward the very good point that
the owners of Austin's do not think this
is viable however we're being told maybe
that doesn't matter because we can
create the scale of seven more Austin's
seven more Austin's in this town the
biggest department store independent
department store in in a very long way
one of the very few that still exists
seven more of those so whilst the rest
of the world is challenged and our
government tell us it's Global this
crisis we're we're all up against it the
American interest rates are rising
inflation is is rampant everywhere
whilst all that is happening Newton
Abbott's gonna have boom time gonna have
boom time I'm Afra I'm afraid this is
just totally delusional
it's uh it it's something that the
residents of of teambridge will will be
holding this Council accountable for in
time I'm afraid to say I think a lot of
this debate is is purely political and
presentational because looking at the
plan there is no potential for this to
be delivered you have run out of Road
the architectural Heritage fund told me
themselves that many many councils are
running out of road on the future High
Street fund people cannot spend in time
people cannot procure the builders uh
the Consultants uh get the planning
permission through so
um
this whole thing's fast school but uh
but more worryingly is is sadly very
delusional and uh and I'm afraid we've
been misrepresented many times in the
counter arguments thank you
thank you uh it's now councilor Cox's
turn to councilman Connaught said that
if we do not find a partner a business
partner who are going to put down their
own money it won't go ahead so
it's a case of you know if we there is
there is that safety catch that Scots or
somebody else will come forward and if
they don't come forward we'll um do that
if we were just going to throw this
money at it I would be be very concerned
and probably vote no we have that safety
catch that there needs to be a
commercial partner and without a
commercial partner it won't go ahead so
I think that's help helpful and I would
love to see the Alexandra theater done
but I do think that Scots will stay put
because they can renew their lease under
the law if we don't go ahead with this
project
um we it may not that if if a commercial
partner is not prepared to put their
money where their mouth is then it won't
go ahead so we can we can be helpful we
can we can be
assured in that respect that it's got to
be commercially viable and there are
different things there is there are
films shown in the Riviera and tinmouth
in The Pavilions in tignmouth uh there's
the timber
Film Society which plays films in
Trinity School it's horses for courses
my kids go to Peyton or Exeter because
they want that experience and they would
probably come to this in Newton ever I
don't know if that makes enough people
but I think that's a commercial decision
for others and they will they will
either if they if they are committed to
it they believe it's going to make money
they'll come and join teambridge if not
we don't take given them the money won't
be there
okay I just counselor Connor so I'm
allowing him to come back obviously his
leader so are there any other speakers
but after this how many times have you
spoken twice already on this item uh
Adrian uh
there is some flexibility it's a very
small point I wanted to make people in
response
just make the a small point now if you
if you want thank you Chad my my
response to councilor Cox was okay we've
got a safety four-back position of um if
the money isn't put in by the private
entity then then we don't we don't um
commit to our money but what what a
great fallback position we can be
reassured that we'll lose the 100 100
with the millions of pounds of the
future High Street fund if it doesn't go
ahead that's a wonderful fallback
position isn't it
well you've had your chance to come out
three times now I've allowed you to
speak
German I just want to ask that I think
it's been an extensive debate the
question is put yeah yes I think it's
time to go to the vote on this uh the
motion has been put before you it's been
uh proposed and seconded and it's time
to go to the debate to the vote Yes
oh yes yes
okay thank you
thanks yep yep
Trish will actually call the names I
think he's calling the names yes thank
you chair councilor Austin
councilor Bradford
cancer Boulevard
councilor cold Clough
councilor connect for councilor David
Cox councilor Hugh Cox
councilor Dewhurst
councilor Goodman Bradbury
councilor Hocking okay
Council Gordon herc oh councilor Jackie
hook
councilor Jeffries
Council Keeling or Newton Abbott okay
councilor McGregor
quiet please
McGregor
[Music]
councilor Parker
councilor patch
councilor John pedrick
I can't say Linda Patrick
cancer Phipps
councilor Purser or
councilor rollerson oh that's the
Russell
councilor Taylor
that's the Thorne
cancel the tomb
sorry it's gone yeah
councilor Wiggly
um apologies councilor door so I missed
you hot I missed your against
um cancer nuttle
on your South chair four
let's go
yeah I think we'd like to hear the
numbers please if we made
I had it at six against with one
abstention I haven't counted The Strokes
I've got here but I can do
24. well I had it did you have it at 24
yesterday yeah it did well the records
there uh who voted for what so it was 24
4 6 uh against wasn't it and one
abstention do you agree with that yeah
right so that concludes that item now
thank you
yes we go to agenda item nine now
um
the executive member for economy and
jobs to move the recommendation
is in my brief on this one it's the
future High Street fund project the
revised business case so
can we have that term item one
start there
thank you chair
it is on
um I'd like to formally move
um the item item nine
um
with recommendation
three to change which would be to lift
the revocation and keep the existing
reporting requirement in place chair
um
so I formally moved that
secondary from
the lights right in the way in the glass
it's rigid feeling isn't it yeah
as you can see the light's right behind
you
so there's a proposure and a second
there so I throw this on to debate
castleconic
chairman I just want to address myself
to item three at the last council
meeting which was adjourned uh the
amendment approved by cancer was to ask
the executive receives a monthly update
which supported all councilors uh
keeping a track on the future High
Street fund the recommendation here to
cancel the revoke requirement is from
officers identify the workload that was
placed on them on on monthly reporting
however mindful of all that is said
whether you are for the 600 000 or
against or whatever I think all of us
would feel that certainly uh for the
next six seven months it'll be really
helpful for councilors to have that
regular update which a place that can be
readily refined and so chairman that's
why uh councilor Jeffries has moved in
recommendations on page 133 moved items
one and two and the deletion of three
because we want to maintain that monthly
reporting chairman and and that is to
which councilor Keeling seconded and I
support one and two and I support uh the
deletion of recommendation three
chairman
Julie noted thank you anybody uh
councilor hook Kathy hook
thank you on um item one
um the revised project scope and
referring to the appendices
um I'm just seeking clarification for
those of us that are planning committee
members I mean I've always been very
clear and stated before that the
planning decisions on the two
applications one for the cinema and one
ultimately for the Market Hall are
completely separate decisions and that
we can comfortably make the decision
we've just made about
um supporting the 600k or otherwise
um but I noticed that appendices some of
the appendices have sketches of the
Market Hall what it might look like and
also Street scenes of the cinema and an
internal layout of the cinema
um so can you just reassure us that by
voting to approve that project scope
with those appendices we are not
predetermining ourselves
thank you yeah I think down the end of
the table yes thank you thank you
chairman um we were comfortable that you
wouldn't be predetermining yourselves
based on that
um because this is about the business
case not about the design and you may
have a completely different view when
you get to a planning committee around
the design elements of it I think this
is the in principle around the the
business case not around the design of
the cinema
can I just ask
Limited
thank you chairman I just want to ask
that question from councilor Jackie Hook
and the reply from the management is
explicitly minuted so everyone is clear
about that sometime later on that this
issue of predetermination doesn't exist
for any counselor thank you well I think
Sarah is assuring us that she's writing
away
so have you got that Sarah
that will be minuted for you
so is there anybody the councilor
Boulevard
sorry just a point of clarity the item
three on the agenda about the reporting
from the officers I recognize the
workload that the officers are under
would you like to change the format of
your reporting to reduce the workload or
would it be appropriate to reduce
the former
thank you
um I might ask Neil to to comment our
basis of reporting was using the
information that the project team used
basically on risk cost
um and the project plan
um we were hoping to simplify as as best
we can
um we we keep the portfolio holder
updated with those basic details
um I'd have to ask the officer directly
Neil
thank you chair um for Council Bluff and
tits the monthly cycle for committee
reports requires obviously the
preparation of the reports the
consultation internally to make sure
you've got all the relevant information
available to you
um and the request was was looking at
um members are about to sign off a
timeline and a budget and a program and
that we'd report back if by exception
you know they weren't being keep to
track so it's
um there's a lot of work involved in
creating it there's times where and in
this instance it will happen in the next
few months there won't be any progress
um so we can obviously be a very
simplified report but it's understanding
I guess the depth of information that's
required Beyond what's already been
approved if if members agree to to sign
this off today but you require updates
on
um and I guess the question is what what
information is the most pertinent to
know and is that something that members
want to see more frequently in members
newsletters for example or is it well I
guess it's Clarity on on what that isn't
already signed off that you're looking
for if everything's on track then
there's not really much to update beyond
what you've already got in front of you
cancer rules
thank you chair
I appreciate the workload that officers
are under and I think they've done a
fantastic job that was really well
endorsed by the audit report which one
of the strengths of the success of the
officers was the reported and
accountability and I think there is a
recommendation in the audit report that
the extra Financial detail is in the
spreadsheet I think it's in
2.31 suggests monthly reporting continue
and that was accepted or was implemented
I believe so we should have
reporting and risk management in every
sense of risk that we face because it's
absolutely vital part of project
management it's like saying we're not
going to do the accounts at the end of
the year or something like that it's
it's a welcome thing it spots troubles
early on so it shouldn't be a worry it
should be an actual help and benefit if
you spot an issue early on or spot an
opportunity early on so I really feel we
should stick with the audit report and
the excellent job that's been done and
not change anything and I support the
motion
so can we go to the vote please on uh
one and two as on page 133 that's been
proposed and seconded can we go to the
vote please
yeah I I don't know whether he wanted it
to be a name vote
so anybody want to stand or are you
happy to go over the street for your
hands right it's hands try and count
them
I don't know
those against
those abstaining
four four
well that brings us to the end doesn't
it Sarah yeah so thank you very much
everybody we've managed to get through
it by 110 so we can go and have some
lunch now and go home as they say thank
you very much everybody for attending